morning thank you Mr
chairman please allow me to give a
little background to this bill before us
1573 you may remember the Scandal
regarding bledo a facility in Tennessee
where two New Hampshire Lads were
sent when Cassandra Sanchez child
advocate went there for a visit she was
appalled and rightly so she decided
immediately something must be done to
change the way we send people to
facilities and asked me to put in a
bill this was done on the Fly because
Bill sponsoring week was about to end so
the original bill
1573 is a
placeholder there are at least three
groups that oversee children in need in
New Hampshire one is the office of the
child
Advocate two others reside within
DHHS one is children's Behavioral Health
the other one is
DCF I asked them to come up with one
Amendment which would be one of those
replace all amendments for the
placeholder I kept at them and while
they got closer and closer and closer to
unanimity squaring the circle great
rejoicing in the land
they could not ultimately come to
unanimity the sticking spot was how
exactly facilities were to Garner State
approval the office of the child
advocate has it one way they want such
facilities to be
0428 DHHS has another way of doing it
they want such facilities
certified that is-
H when the committee researcher gets
here she should be armed with copies of
both of those if you don't somehow have
them
already the bill you may have read is
the placeholder You may wish to read
amendments 0428 and
0427 because these will be the ones put
in
play the difference between the two
amendments is mostly in the middle of
the second
page on 428 it is starting at line 9 on
427 at line
copies in my
opinion the amendment from
DHHS is is the superior
one to come up with a formal
contract as the office of child advocate
would have us do is a good thing except
Contracting takes a lot of time and
effort the needs we have to make sure a
facility is up to standard can
adequately be addressed by the
DHHS amendment in my opinion without the
long time delay that that will need so
with that I put this bill into play Mr
chairman and am willing to take any
questions thank you are there any
representative see you none thank you
sir thank you uh next I'll call up uh
great good morning for the record my
name is Cassandra Sanchez and I'm the
child advocate for the State of New
Hampshire good morning attorney Lissa
masio I'm the associate child advocate
person thank you um so we are here today
in response to
what the office of the child advocate
uncovered this summer at bledo Youth
Academy I do know many on the committee
are familiar but I'm just going to
briefly touch on what occurred in July
during a site visit out of state so the
office of the child advocate traveled to
Tennessee to Gallatin Tennessee for to
visit children in a facility called
bledo Youth Academy this facility is
certified by the state of New Hampshire
as a level three treatment facility we
went to visit youth there and during our
time visiting the facility which we
shared our report um that came out about
a month after our visit we found
horrifying conditions where New
Hampshire children were staying the
standards at this facility were not
standards that the state of New
Hampshire would agree to for our own
children they were degraded in this
facility they were physically harmed by
staff there were excessive restraint
techniques used at this facility as well
as encouraging youth to fight
peer-to-peer in order to earn incentives
and be free from future harm from staff
and the facility what we learned from
these children is they were encouraged
by staff all the way up to the director
of this program to engage in Behavior
where they would either taunt or harass
their
peers in order for them to feel safe in
the facility because they were told that
if they did this they would be protected
from future harm
the children were returned uh about a
month after the oca's visit to this
facility in
Tennesse Upon Us seeing the conditions
in this facility meeting with leadership
meeting with the clinical team and
holding very high concerns for the
safety of our children we immediately
called DHHS from the parking lot of the
facility before we were done our time
there it took an additional month for
these children to come back to New
Hampshire when once they returned to New
Hampshire we had an opportunity to meet
with them in residential facilities here
in state and have follow-up
conversations and check in with these
children to see if they felt safe now
and to learn more about what occurred
for them in that additional month time
frame what we learned from that
additional month time frame was
absolutely horrifying these children
were targeted by staff they were some
were pushed and um their items were
broken their personal items
they were told that they were going to
be sent to another facility and that
there was going to be further harm in
that facility they were told by staff
that they were gang affiliated and the
staff were going to send gang members
after them and their families
threatening to kill their families these
children lived in complete fear they
were so grateful to be back in New
Hampshire they are doing better now but
are still to this day struggling with
the aftermath of the trauma that they
suffered while at bledo Youth Academy
this is a facility that our State
Certified and our state entrusted to
care for our children and they were not
providing any type of care we know our
children that end up in residential
facilities already carry with them a
plethora of trauma whether it be what
occurred to them in their biological
family home the trauma of being removed
from those family settings and then
having to live in a setting with peers
who struggle with a lot of behaviors and
they're exposed to many things when
they're in these settings and so rather
than being able to send these children
to a facility where we could trust that
they were going to provide them not only
the treatment that they needed but
adequate care and Humane treatment our
children got otherwise so this is why we
sit here today and really urge the
committee to take a look at the process
of certifying facilities in New
Hampshire is that enough are we
gathering enough information currently
to ensure that our children will be safe
where they are being placed and the
office of child advocate feels strongly
that the certific certification process
as it stands right now is not doing that
Lissa is going to share with you um some
of our recommendations for amendments to
the bill to further strengthen this
process while also acknowledging that we
do understand the Contracting process
can take some time we do feel that our
children deserve what is best for them
and if it takes time to make that happen
then we need to take the time to
adequately assess them but we do also
understand that there may be times where
a child May be waiting in an emergency
department these are probably the most
calls we're getting dayto day currently
where children are waiting in emergency
departments for a a further placement
and so because of that in our in the
work that we did we did work in so that
they can be placed at a facility while
undergoing the Contracting process so
that we don't let go of the fact that we
need to do the further assessment but we
start with that initial certification
assessment and continue to assess the
program while the child is there until a
contract
can be
completed thank you I just wanted to
touch very briefly on some of the
concerns and um we did hand out copies
of the bledo report the initial August
8th which delves into this issue a
little bit but in the months since then
we've learned even more so I just do
want to reiterate that what we know is
that currently kids in care of the state
being placed by the state are being
harmed and under the current rules laws
administrative rules and procedures and
the current bcbh system of certification
and oversight that's happening they're
being harmed so some of those gaps we
saw was you know how could New Hampshire
children have been placed at a facility
in Tennessee without bcbh ever visiting
that facility there were zero visits
before that facility was certified zero
visits to that facility before children
were placed there very vulnerable
traumatized children sent 2500 miles
away from home and zero visits during
the certification recertification
process which happens every two years
and was actually happening during this
very time frame no visits from bcbh the
certifying agency until after we brought
the issues to their attention that means
no certification officer saw children
wearing colorcoded prison style
jumpsuits no one certifying this
facility saw children sleeping on
mattresses in the hallway because there
had been a flood that never got remedied
and no certification officer seeing the
barbed wire in 24-hour surveillance of
this children yet it got certified and
it got
recertified in addition one of the
biggest concerns we had was the lack of
restraint in seclusion reports a major
part of OCA oversight is reviewing
restraint and seclusion reports from all
facilities where New Hampshire children
are which are required to follow New
Hampshire law but bcbh had decided that
only contracted facilities should have
to send their restraint seclusion
reports to a central reporting location
which OCA had access to certified
facilities were not required to do that
and that was a choice that bcbh made and
continues to make so we continue to not
have access to restraint seclusion
reports for many facilities where New
Hampshire children are because they just
have chosen not to contract them now we
understand Contracting takes time but an
issue here is that this is a choice bcbh
is making there's plenty of certified
facilities that have been certified for
a lengthy period of time and they've
never even been asked to go through the
Contracting process might they say no if
asked maybe but we have no idea so
that's the current process that we go
through as you may know a contract is a
legally binding document certification
is not a contract can be enforced and
here in New Hampshire the purpose of
Contracting is to lend a level of over s
it transparency and accountability that
goes through governor and council
certification is a purely internal
process controlled by administrative
rules that are only in the oversight of
the agency there is no external
oversight of the certification process
other than OCA so that's another
advantage of Contracting is it does lend
this external oversight and it's a
legally binding document and just one
more Point well to go with that under
New Hampshire law any Services over
$10,000 are supposed to go through
governor and Council under mop
150 for some reason these facilities
that as we all know receive tens of
thousands of dollars are Exempted from
that process somehow but finally there's
been a recent Supreme Court decision
here in New Hampshire that the court
itself said when looking at some dcyf
internal policies that the court doesn't
have to adhere to those not to policies
not to procedures and presumably not to
administrative rules because what the
court said was we only look at the
statute the legislature has decided what
it wants the court to follow and they
have to put it into law otherwise the
Supreme Court doesn't have to follow it
so those are all concerns that we were
trying to address by that bill and as
much as it pains me to disagree with uh
your chairperson Pearson we strongly
disagree that the certification process
is adequate because we've seen that it's
not we've seen that BC cbh doesn't even
follow its current certification so I'm
not sure why them bulking up those
certification processes would make any
difference they are still internal only
with no external oversight so just to
take you quickly through the OCA
Amendment and I'm sorry chair Pearson I
did not catch what the number of that
one
was the amendment is uh-
0428 H that's the o C A Amendment and
again it is largely the same we did work
very closely with DHHS to try and come
as close together as we could with
language and really with purpose we all
agree we want to protect our children we
just have a slight disagreement of what
that's going to take so um section one
is a statement of purpose we do believe
that is important that children have
rights and especially when they are in
state care the state has an obligation
to provide appropriate care we are
looking to sort of confine residential
plac replacement to ages 12 and over and
on short-term narrow circumstances only
there are some other bills in the
legislature this session around that
issue including
s417 uh section two of the original bill
was completely deleted because it
actually referenced um not a correct
statutory provision so that's gone
section two of our Amendment and I
believe it's it's consistent with the
DHHS Amendment just has some additional
language around the definitions and the
monitoring to make it internal
consistent uh section three is really
where a bulk of the differences lay as
representative Pearson
stated already facilities have to be
properly licensed that's a separate
section of DHHS that does licensing all
instate facilities have to be licensed
foster homes are licensed Child Care is
licensed separate process in addition
bcbh has that certification
responsibility and Contracting
responsibility for facilities they have
ch chosen to contract our Amendment and
what would be new to the law is OCA
feels very strongly it's important that
all facilities that children are placed
in particularly by the state whether
it's dcyf or bcbh should also be
contracted we did come up with some
compromised language as we stated that
they be contracted or be have at least
initiated the process of Contracting up
to 120 days obviously you all are policy
makers can decide if that's the
appropriate amount of time we do
understand Contracting takes time I
understand the divisions um Contracting
Bureau has been recently increased last
year's budget governor and Council does
meet twice a month um it is a process
but it's not not doable um I would argue
that every vendor with the state is
actually required to be contracted we
don't do business with people who refuse
to sign a contract uh so but we did try
and build some wiggle room in there we
certainly do not want to leave children
without a place to go they should be
certified before a child is placed there
and it already says that we do have
concerns about the um following the
actual current certification process
that really needs to be bulked up eyes
have to be on they need to be doing more
than simply getting resumés and
brochures from facilities they really
need to go investigate and make sure
it's safe even under the current
administrative rules that's not being
done and we hope that it will be part of
that is by um creating a team within the
bureau this would require a little bit
more staff to really make sure that
certification process is being done
thoroughly that they're in-person visits
they're really looking at the program so
uh we'd also ask that that team create a
standard operating procedure form that
OCA would be involved when and just some
of the certification requirements are a
little bit more specific about what
they're looking at it would also require
enhanced monitoring visits currently
they are supposed to be visiting
contracted and certified facilities
every year one year for certification
one year for quality assurance as we
understand that wasn't happening anyway
we would like to see quarterly visits as
you all know there's a push to really
get kids out of residential care so
really hopefully this number is going to
be going down and down and down anyway
but in the meantime we want to make sure
that someone has their eyes on those
children who are in state care to make
sure the facility is the most effective
placement an appropriate placement the
least restrictive
placement I do want to add currently
just so it is very clear when we are
speaking about DHHS there are two
separate entities that are involved with
with these CH children typically we have
the department for children youth and
families that is typically the placing
agency and we have the Bureau of
children's Behavioral Health that is the
one that is certifying and overseeing
these facilities DCF policy stands that
they are required to go to these
facilities once a month to visit with
their children they need to see all
children on their case loads once a
month there was a case work worker out
there every single month in two bledo
between January and July when the OCA
went to visit not one of those DCF case
workers brought forth the concerns that
the OCA found when we went to this
facility so the certification team that
is supposed to be looking at the
physical facility the programming that
they offer and the treatment of the
children had not been out there the
worker that is responsible for checking
in with their child and ensuring that
their needs were met were out there the
problem is is that we need both those
DCF workers are not tasked with doing a
full facility site review that is not
their job when they're going out there
their job is strictly to check in with
their child are your needs being met
here are updates on your case I will see
you next month and we will touch Pace
before then and so there are people
going out there but not the people that
are responsible for holding these
facilities accountable and
accountability is key we do we are not
currently seeing much accountability at
all for these facilities I'll share with
you unfortunately we had to bring forth
at the last oversight commission for
children's services meeting that nationa
Children's Home had used illegal prone
restraint on children that was changed
in the law last year that continued that
occurred in January what is going to be
the accountability for this facility we
have not heard yet we do not have an
update that any action is taken to hold
them accountable for using illegal
restraints we need more accountability
and so that does have to come from that
separate entity but yes have there been
eyes on the children yes not the correct
eyes just want to make sure that piece
is clarified and that was a great segue
because the next section of the bill
section four would add two new sections
to
169f so 169 is the child serving section
of the statute 169b is Juvenile Justice
169 C is abuse and neglect act which is
where the rest of this bill would go
into or most of this bill 169 D is chins
which are children in need of services a
separate section so 169f is a underused
at this point but not if we have our say
because we would like to put stuff in
there it actually it is over the entire
family court division so applies to
judges with court ordered placement
under 169 B C D and court ordered
treatment episodes a treatment placement
that'd be bcbh so 169f is a catchall to
make sure all courts overseeing kids
that the state put somewhere would do
these things so the first section is
around those monthly visits that
Cassandra was just talking about which
are required and are being done right
now but sometimes can be as short as 15
minutes literally just putting their
eyes on the kid you look okay to me it
can often be a different person um
cassandre mentioned there had been seven
workers that was seven different workers
none of whom were actually the
children's case workers they didn't know
these people seven different strangers
coming to visit for 15 minutes in a
little conference room those kids did
not disclose anything to any of those
folks when the OCA showed up who did
have relationship with these kids
disclosures so it is important for
children when they're being visited to
actually know the person for the person
to know something about the child and
the family and the case so the new
section would require that the worker
visiting is either the child's actual
worker we understand that is not always
possible or at least someone that knows
something about the case could be that
person's supervisor a former worker the
assessment worker somebody that knows
something about that child and that case
and preferably the same person more than
once so the child can build some Rapport
we are also asking for that visit to be
bulked up a little bit not a whole site
visit like bcbh does but take a look
around at least look and see where the
kid's sleeping see where they're eating
if you go to a foster home a worker
would do that they go look at the kids'
room they talk to the other people in
the house look in the kitchen that's not
happening at residential facilities
which makes no sense because a child
who's living in a foster home has
teachers doctors counselors other people
that see that child if they were
concerns they could call raise the red
flag a residential facility that's the
only people that have their eyes on that
kid so to not check out the facility
means Nobody seeing is that kid sleeping
on a mattress in the hallway does is
their room stripped of all personal
belongings is there food in the kitchen
so just a little bit more of a visit it
does not have to be extensive also
checking in which is required but just a
little bit broader of we're checking
about the therapeutic culture we're
checking how the kids doing with their
therapist with the teacher things that
get done by every DCF worker
particularly a kid in a foster home but
seem to being missed a little bit
especially children far away that would
also develop a new form with OCA to make
sure that consistent recordkeeping is
happening so that the OCA oversight is
actually effective we can't effectively
oversee if we can't see what's happening
the last section is aimed at the court
oversight of residential placement which
is also essential to protecting these
children currently the court just gets
the information the division gives it's
not always thorough the court may not
know which placement is most effective
for a child they're really just taking
what the the division's giving them so
this section bulks up again in 169f so
that it does apply to children in
Juvenile Justice in chins in abuse and
neglect but really delves into what the
assessment has to say prior to placement
to make sure residential placement is
appropriate what review hearings look
like having them be more frequent what
um documentation is provided at that
review hearing both to the court as well
as to the parties to make sure these
children are not languishing in a
placement that's simply not appropriate
to them you know we are short on beds we
are short on placements but a child
shouldn't be sent especially thousands
of miles away and just left there you're
done we placed you we're not doing
anything else so this really builds up
the framework to let the court do their
job because you know we do have separate
branches for a reason Court oversight is
essential to protect these children as
well and then finally uh there's a new
section at the end um that got uh left
off of the original bill this is also
important reallocation of funds um
frankly in other states that have been
trying to bring their children home and
get the matter of residential placement
this has just been essential to making
this work reallocating any funds that
are recouped from not sending children
to these extremely expensive residential
placements and again this is taxpayer
money recouping it but keeping it within
the system it doesn't just go back into
General funds it needs to be then used
to bulk up the Community Based Services
because as we all know and the new dcy
director has talked about in order to
keep kids in their communities whether
it's their home kin fictive kin even
foster homes in their communities you
need those intensive wraparound services
to make sure that they are safe so in
order to recapture that money that would
have gone to residential
placement in back into those community
services and if I didn't mention before
another big thing about Contracting is
simple fiscal responsibility as
mentioned in the blood sore report we
spend a lot of money putting these kids
in placements that are potentially
harming them and we are responsible to
the taxpayers in that process of
Contracting to have that executive
Council oversight which is what it was
created for is really important for
fiscal responsibility as well as the
safety of our
children I that was a lot of information
but we're here to answer questions as
well thank you we're open to questions
okay great thank you any questions um I
do have uh with with respect to um
contracts and certification in a
certification can you require that
certification to follow restraining laws
restraint laws in New Hampshire it can
our worry is the accountability piece
with a contract you have a legally
binding document and so if they're not
upholding that then there is the
opportunity to hold them accountable to
that we have believed all along that
whether certified or contracted all
residential reporting should come
centrally should be overseen that still
has not happened and that has been an
Ask of the office of the child advocate
from before I joined the office so I I
would guess from the Inception of the
office that has been an Ask okay and uh
follow up the the
um contract I would suspect you could
breach the contract however what are you
doing an emergency when you're breaching
a contract and you're pulling like the
two children that we pulled from bledo
uh wouldn't that create more of an
emergency even even current Contracting
and certification process both and it's
actually within the bill as well there
are corrective action plans I mean
usually in any contract the first breach
is not immediate cancellation of that
contract you usually do a corrective
action plan that is built into the
statutes already but could be easier to
enforce with an actual contract as well
as you then have that Outside Agency
governor and councel that could be you
know pushing that there's not been
enough corrective action um but frankly
it's a problem now even with certified
and contracted facilities cassandre
mentioned NCH constant violations not
just of the contract but of children's
rights in abuse then is not nothing's
being done and part of that's licensing
it is a complex issue there are multiple
factors but absolutely it should be
enforcable but it doesn't necessarily
mean we're shutting you down could just
be corrective action okay and with res
respect to the reallocation of money
monies that's at stfe for example the
Bureau of children Behavioral Health
that that funding will stay to them and
the dcyf funding will stay with them or
does it go to
DHHS for reallocation the way in which
it is written it is Broad um for that
purpose I ideally in the conversations
that we've had with the agency which
they did not argue this point um is to
agree that if a child is coming from a
residential facility and requires more
intensive Services the funds that would
have been going into the residential
facility should follow that specific
child into their community services so
that could be a service that is better
fit for them that's offered through DCF
or it could be a community based service
through bcbh so that's why it's left
more broadly so that DHHS can put the
funds wherever that specific child needs
them and we know the agency is working
really hard to to kind of break down
those silos you know we have meetings
monthly with Jeff and with Jeff and
katcha and bcbh and Christa and Marissa
that they're working really hard to make
sure that the children's system of care
the way it's being built out is
accessible obviously there are still
barriers there's still a lack of
services but we we have faith that they
they have that in mind that they want
services to be available and they will
get creative to make it work great any
further questions representative gibons
thank you Mr chairman um just to could
you provide context how how full as far
as um capacity are these residential
facilities so in other words if one was
to be shut down and the kids were moved
into different facilities would would
other facilities be able to absorb them
or or would we be in some type of crisis
with with where to place them we are we
are definitely in a placement crisis
already um and one of the major issues
is Staffing some of the facilities do
not have the ability to fill all of
their beds because they do not have
adequate Staffing right now um and so
this is where our children who are
higher need end up being sent out of
state because the programs in state have
more children to pick from and they may
pick a child who doesn't have aggressive
behaviors versus one that does and then
the one that does is the child that's
sent out of state uh but we also know
that there are many children lingering
in residential care that do not need
that level of care they should be in
foster homes they should be with fictive
kin and so that is our our constant push
on the agency as well is moving these
children along and in some of the
language in this bill assists with that
where it's really focusing on what
what is Residential Treatment it is a
shortterm episode of treatment to then
return to a community setting for
continued outpatient level treatment and
again it's not necessarily the goal of
us sorry I can't see you while speaking
theone of of either the OCA or the
agency or this bill to shut places down
yes bledo needed to be frankly they
haven't been shut down we're just not
sending children there anymore because
that was really a dangerous
inappropriate placement but we hope that
this enhancement of um the review the
oversight the interaction will help
facilities raise their standards by
force if necessary to be appropriate for
our children we we do not want our
children in unsafe ineffective
inappropriate
placements um what what type of uh staff
are are overseeing these kids in these
facilities are they um like lnas are
they nurses like what type of do they
have their own licenses uh the the
Direct Care staff which are the ones
that work specifically with the children
they're the ones that do their evening
routine get them to bed um their their
regular schedule they are um not paid
very well um there's not high degree
requirements for that job um but we do
understand that the pay is really what
is losing a lot of folks in that field
because they are able to go to say a
fast food restaurant and make more money
there and have less stress than working
with kids with high needs um but it's
not a they're not highlevel positions to
fill they do have clinical positions on
staff but they're not the ones that are
in the millu with the children they are
doing an hour a week of therapy maybe
two if they're doing an hour of family
therapy an hour of individual therapy um
so it's it is primarily those Direct
Care staff and so when we're going into
facilities and we're assessing and and
seeing a concern we're really focusing
on what education may they need because
they don't have high education
requirements to fulfill the job so what
trainings can be brought in to help the
staff lead more trauma informed
practices um what kind of Consultants
can come into the facility and and CH
and help shift the culture in the
overall facility so there's a lot of
work that can be done as Lisa mentioned
before getting to the point of um either
canceling a contract or decertifying a
you uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I have two
things things and the first one is I
wondered if you had any more copies of
the report because we are short five on
this end of the table um and the second
is regarding um training for staff who
will be doing these visits both through
uh the quarterly visits and the annual
unannounced but for the monthly visits
for the dcyf worker uh hopefully someone
who knows the child but even if it is
you know the rotating group of workers
that it has been what kind of um
training would become available because
if we now are mandating that they do
specific things which is in my opinion
entirely
appropriate is there a training that
will teach them how to notice these
signs so that these things don't fall
through the cracks again so one of the
reasons why um we added a form in
Creation with the OCA is to give them a
guide when they're out at these
facilities oftentimes there's there's so
much going on when you walk into a
residential facility and you're there on
a mission to see your child make sure
they're okay and then get to the next
visit because as you know the days are
so busy doing this work um and so the
form is really just the guide because
they already are trained to look for
these things when they're going through
the regular DCF training they they're
looking for them as Lisa mentioned in
foster homes they're are they already
have that I it's when there's so much in
front of them having that guy telling
them first you're going to go look at
the child's bedroom and you're going to
report what you saw in the bedroom then
you're going to sit down and talk with
the child and ask them about their
experience ask them about therapy ask
them about schooling right and and
giving them a guide for every topic to
discuss so that they're not missing
something should be the piece that ties
back into all of the training that they
already received and their initial
Social Work training and the additional
trainings that they are offered through
the agency and we would like to be a
part of that because we are doing those
site visits and that is something that
DHHS has been open to is to allowing us
one to work on things like a forum like
this or even to come in and present to
their staff how we operate in our site
visits thank you I I would just like to
add the workers at DCF I I worked at DCF
you know the folks at bcbh they are
well-trained folks a lot of them have a
lot of experience it's not that these
are all new things they're looking for
frankly this is really what they have
been or should have been looking for all
along but by spelling it out in statute
it makes it clear it makes it more
enforcable but these are the types of
things they would be looking for it
just hasn't been written in law that
this is what you need to you need to
take the time to look at the the room to
to see the environment so I don't know
that this is all new stuff like they
haven't been doing any of this but
because of what we saw at bledo we just
want to make it crystal clear in the law
that it is the policy and the law of the
state that they do this yeah follow up
I'm just going to ask it thanks um so
regarding um are there any circumstances
where um we're finding that the workers
are being denied access to like the
rooms where the the children are staying
I'm just I'm trying to recall I worked
for TCF years ago here in New York as
well and frequently when you visit a
child in a residential placement there's
like a visitation room right as opposed
to going to that that child's actual
bedroom where they're staying um have we
had any trouble with people accessing
those rooms and do we think that
spelling it out in statute would be
helpful we have not heard any
difficulties with accessing the room we
always ask to see where children stay um
and we've never been denied either they
have the same access to children as the
OCA would have and so there should not
be any denial of allowing them into
those into all different areas of the
facility thank you thank you
thank you Mr
chairman and Miss Sanchez and it's
attorney Matthew Matthew M par me
attorney attorney massio uh specific to
um comments that you made that when uh
visits have been made to the subject
property as I'll call it that uh it was
found they were not following quote
rules when they're out of state what uh
sense or guarantee would we have they
would follow our rules when they're the
authority having
jurisdiction so they do have their own
licensing entity and so our state
through the certification process is
required to touch base with their
licensing entity ensure that they do
have an active license in place um so
they do have that they also have their
own child welfare system who does the
oversight if there's any concerns of
abuse or neglect they're called into
their facility which was part of this
process we did call in abuse and neglect
to their child welfare agency so
although they have their own entities we
are the one that are placing the
children there our state of New
Hampshire is placing the children there
the state of New Hampshire is funding
the beds that those children are staying
in and so that this brings it back again
to the importance of a contract in a
contract you're saying you provide X Y
and Z service to our children we provide
you this funding and then if they're not
meeting the services that they they
agreed to pay for you're saying you're
not meeting the contract and we have an
ability to hold you to that because we
have in writing that you're going to
provide this and we know you're not
but that is what the importance of more
regular in-person visits because it's
very difficult to be alerted of these
things when it is out of state and if
the state isn't there on a regular basis
are they truly catching them or is it
going to be a year later after they were
certified and they're going back out to
to see the facility so the quarterly
visits would also show a presence there
and we have heard from some residential
facilities I heard Vermont is one
actually that Vermont goes out monthly
with their folks that do the
certification process and so facilities
know when the state of Vermont is coming
and they know that they need to have
everything in order because they are
going to be there on a regular basis so
that presence is critical to hold them
accountable to what they're telling us
they're going to provide our children
and they folks that take New Hampshire
children whether it's Contracting or
certification are required to follow New
Hampshire law as it relates to those
children particularly 126 U which is in
the contract and in the certification
rules that they must follow our 126 U
because those are our kids paid for our
money but again there's been a lot of
instances as we discussed NCH even right
here in New Hampshire that simply aren't
following the rules so it's that next
piece of accountability oversight and
enforcement of you're not following
those rules being able to get the
restraint seclusion reports to a
centralized area which is not currently
happening with certified facilities like
bledo would also have additional
oversight by bcbh CER certification by
the OCA so they are required to follow
New Hampshire rules laws as it relates
to New Hampshire children but it's
whether or not we catch them so that's
where the additional accountability is
required one followup Mr chairman
followup sure specific to uh attorney to
your comment just then uh on these bledo
being quote certified so-called if
they're not performing to the
certification and then we have our
representative or Representatives
visiting why are they not terminated
immediately since our children being
view that was I thank you Yan I'm not
the attorney but I will take that
question um that was a question that we
came back with that was our question is
if we saw something so egregious as this
why were the children not immediately
removed as an emergency and brought back
to Safety in New Hampshire it did not
occur swiftly it took a month to get the
children back it took at least an
additional month month from the time the
children returned to desertify the
program and and that for us is too long
and too much of an opportunity for our
children to be In Harm's Way is 100% of
our uh clients out of bledo now yes and
they are officially decertified at this
time and during that period though there
there was another child being considered
to be sent there so it needs to be a
fast process because you know if the
left hand's not talking to the right
hand but you know the contract ing piece
of that does give that extra level but
it doesn't always have to be
cancellation of contract that you know
in a contract you can build in
Provisions for oversight and you know
enforcement understood thank you Mr
chairman bet further questions uh
representative
grman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you to the office of child advocate for
all the work you do and for bringing
this forward um so we're talking about
outof State residential treatment right
now for our instate treatment are we
certifying or
Contracting so instate we have both so
all facilities are certified in state we
have a number of facilities that are
also contracted the priority of DHHS was
to First contract in state facilities
then to work in the New England region
so there are a number of facilities in
state of Massachusetts um possibly
Vermont and Maine as well that are also
contracted we have
asked how the order of preference was
determined what the next preference
would be for additional contracts and
have not been able to get a clear answer
on that question um but from when I
first joined the office and was learning
about the um Bureau of children's
Behavioral Health process and the
Contracting that they were undergoing at
that time was told that the intention
was to continue to expand contracts to
more facilities over time we have not
seen that change occur yet follow up
is the Nasha a children's home
contracted or certified they are both
thank
you representive
deimon thank you Mr chair I'd like to go
back for a minute um and get some real
numbers here if if that if that's okay
yes thank you so much for taking my
question and all that you do thank you
um how many children on a regular basis
annually are uh placed out of state
approximate so those numbers have
reduced greatly since our blood cell
report and so we've been tracking them
very closely since that time frame y
they are I can I've brought my my recent
data Report with me
um and so we have so typically there's
around 300 to 350 children placed in
residential care
overall and um out of those primarily
they're in New
Hampshire currently as of the the last
data point that we had there were 81 in
the New England region the New England
region has always been very high and
there are down to four nationally when
we first began looking at this issue
there
were about 20 that were National and
there had been times in the past that
they were higher than that thank
you and how many facilities do we use on
a regular basis to place these children
in between New England bledo and
wherever else we have a large number of
facilities um that number is changing
because there's additional ones are
added and and um taken out quite
frequently my understanding is there
there are 44 that are contracted
facilities and there are approximately
additional 42 or so that are not and
those are out of state they are there
may be one or two that are in state but
they're primarily out of state okay one
more please sure thank you and how many
inspectors do we have employed in the
state of New Hampshire for these
facilities I can't speak to the
licensing inspectors um but I can speak
to um the bcbh certification team and
currently that team is a team of
three and that we understand that is why
they're asking for additional positions
with this bill to be able to bulk up
that team for for travel purpos to how
many to how
many it has changed and they're here yes
I would I would Reserve that question
for them because I do believe we saw a
different number in the recent fiscal
sure one final final sure thank you I
know I said one more but I lied um have
have you a reason have you been given a
reason why it took a month to get those
kids out of that please
place not a reason in which we could
understand thank you very much for your
time any further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you uh now I have two cards here uh both
Miss okay so could I call all uh six of
you
forward
okay and and then I have another card
for uh M Mr
okay go ahead
miss good
morning my name is Marissa hen I'm the
Deputy Commissioner at the department
for Health and Human Services um and
here here today of course to provide
information on HB 1573 relative to the
oversight and criteria for residential
placement of
children I want to start just by
thanking um representative Pearson and
the other sponsors for their commitment
that we share to prioritizing the
well-being and safety of children and
allowing us to provide information about
how we remain um committed to working on
that mission um I also want to thank the
office of the child advocate who you've
just heard from at length um um we have
been deeply involved in
collaboration for many months um as we
work together to strengthen the
residential treatment system and the
children's Behavioral Health System of
care as a
whole the OCA deserves great credit for
their work bringing this issue to the
for and engaging with us as partners in
pursuit of our common goal to support
Youth and
families and I have to say I will pause
you know one of the things I've always
appreciated about representative Pearson
the the the um primary sponsor of this
bill is his ability to bring thoughtful
people together on issues of of common
ground and um one of the things that
struck me as I was listening to the
oca's testimony is how unfortunate it is
that when we agree on 99% of what is in
a bill like this that at times the
impression that we are conveying to you
all is that we are in disagreement that
there are lack of protections that we
don't trust one another that we don't
believe in the common goal that we hold
dear um that could not be more far from
the truth and the allegations and some
of the falsehoods that were just made
around the lack of protections the harms
occurring to kids the nature of
Contracting the legal basis for
Contracting there's so much to unpack
there and to me it suggests that um I
have a tall task ahead of me in terms of
unpacking that for you all and and
actually correcting the record but also
that we have a lot more work to do to
help educate the office of the child
advocate in terms of how our system
actually works in terms of the
protections and how we are advancing
that common goal and so um I would just
urge you to to listen to what I have to
share recognizing that if you simply
listen to what was just shared you would
think that we're actually in opposition
to this bill when there could be nothing
further from the truth we at DHHS are
deeply grateful for the work of the OCA
representative Pearson and all of you
for considering these important reforms
there is basically one uh technical
detail we want to urge you to reconsider
um in the interest of of best serving
the children of New Hampshire so I just
want to preface with that that um I hope
to take the high road here in terms of
emphasizing
collaboration my plan was not to
readjudication
with the OCA and many other partners
across the state to get kids um from
that outlier program home safe but but
let's stick with this bill for the
moment and I can answer your questions
as they arise so essentially as I said
99% of this bill we completely agree
with we think that this is a step
forward in terms of our ability to keep
kids safe when they do require this
level of episodic care in a specialized
residential program there is one thing
that we disagree with that in in the
Amendments as representative Pearson
introduced and essentially that one
thing is the requirement that all
residential programs be contracted and I
want to just carefully explain why
requiring contracts for all programs
will be a step backward for New
Hampshire Youth and the systems we're
building to serve
them so first Contracting is not what
ensures safety and quality in New
Hampshire certification is how that is
achieved certification is what sets a
very high bar that has only grown higher
in recent months as we collabor collate
with the OCA with Advocates with uh many
legislators to strengthen our system and
ensure the accountability to keep kids
safe we have a robust certification and
licensing process um whether the program
is contracted or not so let me be clear
all programs must be certified whether
they are contracted or not so contracts
are really primarily a financial
mechanism that we use for the programs
we rely on the most so programs that are
in New Hampshire or in our neighboring
states
are contracted there's 21 contracts um
we've been bring bringing forward uh a
number of uh enhancements to rates to
help ensure that the um availability the
access the quality of those programs is
as high as possible um Contracting takes
a lot of time it involves significant
negotiations um and so it's right for
the for the vast majority of programs
and I think that's what was lost in the
testimony you just heard for 99% and I'm
not exaggerating literally 99%
all but four kids current as of today um
served in our residential treatment
program they are in contracted programs
here in New Hampshire or in New England
um and so again we we this is the norm
what we are talking about is that
occasionally for 1% So currently
representing four
children from the state of New Hampshire
we have youth who have a very
specialized level of Need for which a
contracted program does not exist and if
a youth needs a program that does not
exist through contract we need to do
everything we can working with their
parents working with case workers who
serve them working with agencies to
engage in a nationwide search to find a
program that can serve them we utilize a
clinically based assessment Pro um
process that individualizes these
placement decisions and so I just want
to emphasize a very small number four
today out of roughly 400 who are being
served are we have to look for these
specialized programs and we leave no
Rock um
unturned I wish that New Hampshire and
our New England states could provide
this but the truth is some kids have
really special needs um and I'll give an
example um without again you know we
have just putting together kind of
common cases that I learn about let's
say that we have a a girl with reactive
attachment disorder it turns out that
rad reactive attachment disorder doesn't
have a lot of Provider doesn't have any
providers in New England or New
Hampshire included that we can contract
with there are programs outside of our
region so for that young lady and for
her family and others who are
Desperately Seeking to get her that
Specialized Care we need to be able to
accommodate the occasional oneoff
programs and it's not like we just send
a girl like that to a program and say
good luck we engage in a deep and robust
process of certification again
certification is the key word here to
ensure her quality and safety
so I'll actually hold up there is a 48
page guide to all the requirements for
certification this is not a light
process is not a process we take lightly
um our program visits uh the program
initially we engage in an in-depth tour
we interview their clinical staff we
ensure per your thoughtful question that
they meet all of the requirements the
training the certification we complete
file reviews we so we randomly select
files to ensure that the quality of
treatment the therapeutic modalities
that are utilized are meeting our
expectations for the State of New
Hampshire we um analyze how they assess
Youth and engage in treatment planning
we review their daily notes we review
their clinical notes how they do
discharge incident reports um reports of
uh restraint and seclusion again for the
OCA to say that we are um you know sort
of willy-nilly sending kids into
programs that it could not be further
from the truth there's also an indeep
set of documents that we go through
looking to see if they are in good
standing with the state in which this
program is located so we look for other
um reports of what could be occurring
there we look to ensure that um they
have uh they're in compliance with all
the licensing requirements in their home
state and we don't just stop there we
also engage in annual visits um as well
as a combination of uh technical
assistance visits to help them improve
their performance um youth from DCF who
are the who are largely those who are
served out of the in these programs are
visited every month and again just to
correct the record these are not 15
minut minute visits where we pick up
some pamphlets as you just heard these
are in-depth visits we take them
extremely seriously we check on the
youth under our care we interview them
this is um this is we are we have a
critical responsibility serving often um
in the role of parents and in our um
obligations uh as a department and so it
um it gives me goosebumps to imagine the
notion that we would um do anything but
the most robust protections and beyond
that we don't even just do this initial
and these Milestone annual visits we
also have numerous protections should
anything concerning arise in the
meantime so any concerns around
potential abuse or neglect we have an
entire special investigations unit
within dcyf who investigates
institutional abuse we have the we work
with the Department of Justice we work
with the office of the Ombudsman within
DHHS we have child care licensing we
have the Bureau for children's
Behavioral Health and under our
leadership in the commissioner's office
we engage these groups together to
identify kids who may be in a situation
where we need to take urgent action
that's exactly what happened with bledo
and once that case was risen we took
that action so safety requirements and
safety violations are all part of that
certification it's a robust it's not a
one-time process it's ongoing it ensures
that youth are safe um as it pertains to
the placement of Youth you know
contracts are largely a mechanism for
payment um to think that there's
something magical about
contracts the truth is contracts have to
be monitored they have to be enforced
guess who's responsible for doing that
not a third party DHHS so to think that
there's something about Contracting that
is advantageous is just simply untrue so
I want to emphasize again that
certification is required of all
residential programs serving New
Hampshire youth it is a high bar and
once they engage in this process it's
been considered so rigorous that some
providers decide that they don't even
want to be certified in which case we
would never send a youth to such a
program
no child would ever be sent to a program
that is not certified and this has
nothing to do with whether they are
contracted or not the second point I
want to make Beyond clarifying that this
is about certification and not the
financial mechanism of Contracting as
well as the point that this is 1% of the
youth that we're talking about is that
if we require contracts for that 1% of
cases we are going to actually cause
harm to youth so take for example a
child with a serious emotional
disturbance and a co-occurring
developmental disability or medical
fragility who whose issues and needs
have escalated and the family is at
their Wits End perhaps they're even
sitting in the windowless room of an
emergency department waiting as their
insurance company as case workers as our
DHHS teams search for the right program
this is what's happening if we have to
wait for governor and Council to meet
once a month that's an additional series
of weeks of waiting for that child with
specialized needs to get into the
program that he or she deserves we are
not looking to sidestep responsibilities
or legal um protections for anyone the
we're we're trying to navigate
complicated bureaucratic processes to
get families what they need quickly I
believe we've distributed to you um a
flowchart that describes our Contracting
process if anyone would like to reform
our Contracting process you are more
than welcome um but let's just say New
Hampshire um uh has made it for good
reason very um complicated and long each
one of the steps in that flowchart takes
three to four weeks on average I won't
Bore You by going through every step it
requires reviews by the Attorney General
it requires reviews by the department of
administrative Services there's a reason
why in the Live Free or Die state things
move a little more slowly in government
and it's we have we have this entity
called governor and councel so there I'm
not I'm not complaining about the
process I'm just observing that if we
want to get that one % of kids into a
specialized placement we cannot rely
upon this bureaucratically heavy slow
system or we are going to have kids
languishing in the wrong places um a
soul Source contract which is what we're
talking about would take on average
about 120 days to complete so that's 120
days an unacceptable amount of time for
a child to be waiting and waiting when
they are in crisis and so we need that
flexibility and efficiency to occasion
Al engage in a process to get that kid
into the most appropriate level of care
and then ensure all those enforcement
and protection mechanisms that I went
through before are in place to ensure
that their safety and well-being is
always the priority I also want to
mention that if we were to require
Contracting for that additional 1% since
we already have it for the 99% it could
really negatively impact other parts of
our system so for example right now if a
child needed our highest level of care
level which is a psychiatric Residential
Treatment Facility but they're currently
in a level three um that is basically
going to create an issue of
bottlenecking in the system where they
can't move because they can't get uh
space um due to the child who's waiting
for their SE it so essentially you're
not just impacting that one child who's
going to be sitting in an emergency
department or in another desperate
situation waiting to get into care
you're also bottlenecking the entire
process for youth who may need to move
between levels as their therapeutic
needs
change um and so again I just want to
say that we recognize what the OCA is
trying to do we agree with
9999 you know probably 99.9% of it as
reflected in this very thoughtful bill
they have helped Craft um simply having
to go through governor and counsel and a
Contracting process does not add value
here it will do harm um and to think
that contracts offer something magical
or that certific the claim that
certification is not legally binding is
completely untrue the courts have that
um rules and the process of
certification very much is legally
binding and so this could really have
harms to our youth and and again I'll
just close by saying that you know I
began by saying that we want to be
collaborative here we want to be open we
want to be transparent we want to avoid
kids needing Residential Care whenever
possible keep them in a homelike setting
wrap supports around their families
around their communities to keep them
well and to keep them thriving in those
rare times that a youth needs
residential treatment we need to ensure
that those programs are top quality that
they're meeting New Hampshire's high
standards and that there are Protections
in place so that if something is
occurring that should not that we ensure
those kids are moved to a more
appropriate and safe location we are
committed to working with the OCA
actively to move this work forward if we
require Contracting for every certified
program again this would affect four out
of 400 kids um it is going to be a major
step back it's going to add time it's
going to add
bureaucracy um and and frankly just as
Lisa said we want to avoid having kids
languishing in inappropriate care we
could not agree more that's the very
reason why we ask you to advance the
amendment in which we have asked for the
flexibility for this very small number
of Youth to be able to serve them to
reassure their families we can get them
care in an appropriate place and that we
will keep them safe um we believe that
our amendments supports that mission um
thanks so much for the opportunity to
provide feedback and both myself and our
um team are happy to answer any
questions great any questions
representative p uh
Raymond thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um so my
question is on the process of
Contracting so the amendment offered by
the office of the child advocate asks on
page two line 13 and 14 it says um and
contracted by the department or at least
have initiated the process of
Contracting to be completed as
expediently as possible so as I'm
reading that not being an attorney it
sounds to me like if there is a child
who needs for example a level five
placement that a child could be placed
there as long as we have initiated the
Contracting process with that placement
is that am I misreading that because it
sounds to me like the child could be
placed there while the contract is being
negotiated yeah let me I'm going to call
up um Rebecca Ross who's an attorney by
training and also the director of the uh
Bureau for children's Behavioral Health
to to answer that thoughtful question
thank
you morning for the record Rebecca Ross
the director of The Bureau for
children's Behavioral Health if I
understand your question correctly um
you're asking if the bill represents
that all we would have to do is begin
the contract ing process in order to
place a youth is that
correct yes my question is would so that
there would not necessarily be that
bottleneck um but then I guess my the to
further the question is um you now have
six months to get that Contracting
process banged out before you have to
make a decision on whether or not um the
contract is not going to happen in a
different placement would have to happen
right so the problem with that process
is that the purpose of the contract is
to have a meeting of the Mind on what
they're going to provide and what we are
going to pay um if they start performing
under that contract they will be
expecting payment if GNC has to approve
it GNC May disagree and then New
Hampshire is in the position where
another provider has detrimentally
relied Upon Our representation that we
would contract with them um the decision
makers have chosen not to and we still
owe them the money so in order to be in
a place where we have a binding contract
that represents what we're actually
agreeing to we need to do that before
they're providing the service
um this sets up a framework where we're
constantly in the place that we have to
agree to whatever terms that a provider
is um offering because we have to enter
a contract because they're already
may thank you so under because this is
the Crux of the difference between both
of your bills because you both require
you know um extensive visits and and
follow-ups and and I I love that about
both of them so for your bill in that
same situation we have a child who needs
a higher level placement you would place
them with the certific under a
certification process right without
doing a contract Would we not still be
required to pay for the service and I
mean I guess my question is what's
the what's the the difference to the
child that we're talking about between
creating a contract that could maybe be
used for other children or not creating
a contract like what's the difference
for the service provision and our
ability to make sure that the kid is
getting appropriate services in a safe
way practically speaking for a single
individual going to an out ofate
provider none um the history behind the
contracts more relates to systemwide
change and transformation to create a
network of providers that meet all of
New Hampshire's youth's needs but for a
single child if we're certifying a
program we're taking them as they are at
that time agreeing they're able to
provide the service for that youth um
and doing it under our certified rules
and paying an established rate okay
thank you you're welcome for the
questions representative in
van thank you Mr chairman uh for M M
Ross or director Ross either works want
want to address you correctly um
specific uh
to what was uh offered by your colleague
next to you is that we a certification
uh process not process certification uh
for qualification to provide services to
our youth one and then once we have that
certification for the
purposes delineated that are provided at
that
Source a contract would be for a
specialized application within those
Services would that be a correct
interpretation of the
process
I'm not sure I'm completely following
yes a contract would be above and beyond
any of the certification requirements so
the contracts require that they are
licensed within their own jurisdiction
certified for payment by bcbh comply
with the Medicaid rules and
certification standards and then a
contract would be on top of
that followup Mr chairman followup sure
thank you sir uh and and in the uh
interest of the timing for the services
as stated by you ladies in the critical
mass we're dealing with and that get we
have to get it done while we're young
here and when we're doing it is um if
the certifications are being met there
there's a wording here I think is wrong
it says but a no less than 120 days we
want no more than 120 days I would think
in terms of um signing a contract for
specific services and would that meet
the the uh I trying to read these
amendments as fast as possible here is
that what you're not that would you be
in agreement with that that it would be
120 days or less for any special
application to meet this the service
required by our New Hampshire youth well
I think that's the oca's proposal so I
would let them speak to what their
intent was but we believe the
certification process meets that need
and we would not be proposing to do it
within that 120
days um Mr chairman follow up sure when
you said would not you would not do it
within 120
days is that what you just said I we're
not proposing to do it within any time
frame because we believe the
certification process is sufficient for
the programs that we're using for single
youth um but the OCA would be the best
party to speak to their intent with that
120 days and just to get you one more
time Mr chairman please sure uh
therefore then the contract would be
moot in terms of application
of the process whereas the certification
has already set the
standard correct thank you thank you
very much thank you Mr chairman
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you for being here
and explaining the situation and taking
the questions how many facilities are
you placing children with at this
current time that you're not that do not
have a contract with
you so we have a little over 44 programs
that are contracted some of those are um
provided by the same entity so we have
less contracts than we have programs
because they provide different Services
we have a little under 100 um certified
providers so roughly half um but as
Deputy Commissioner hen stated the
majority of the youth we're serving are
in our contracted programs we do have um
four youth that are outside of New
England in non-contracted
programs and then another
um handful or so that are in New England
programs that do not have contracts
because when we started the Contracting
process we went out to bid um and we
entered into contracts with the
individuals that put bids in that wanted
to do business with us um when those
didn't meet the needs we continue to use
some of our other regular Partners to
meet the needs of the remainder of the
youth okay
follow yes thank you now it's a actually
kind of a separate question but you
outlined like how careful you are and
that you have this process where people
go check and you know that that you you
know you have more than a 15 M minute
visit I that doesn't explain bledo to me
if you have all of these safeguards and
you have all of these things that you're
happen so again I think the purpose of
this hearing today is is not necessarily
A's concerns extremely seriously we'd
seen the youth just a couple weeks
before um had not observed the same
conditions the youth did not report them
to us in the same way that um they were
observed and so we immediately initiated
an investigation and I want to emphasize
that um well to an outsider it may sound
like three or four weeks is a long time
um part of what we were trying to do is
the whole reason again these youth were
out of the region is because there
weren't services that met their needs
here in New England a transition to a
new program is in inherently traumatic
in and of itself for youth who have been
shuttled between programs and Foster
homes perhaps for their entire lives and
so we needed to make sure that we had a
safe place for them to return to and
balance the risks as we worked with
Tennessee authorities and the OCA um to
ensure there was um you know there was
safe plans of care in the meantime so um
again I think what rather than
readjudication
what I will say is we feel confident
that thanks to the OCA raising the alarm
and our ability to mobilize teams to get
down there and to um and to to build on
what had been previously observed and um
reported to us we were able to work
collaboratively with Tennessee
authorities and with our own um teams
here in New Hampshire to get the youth
um back to Safe places so I don't you
know while I think bledo was a a
terrible um uh situation I'm so grateful
that uh the state was able to return
those youth safely I also don't know
that focusing on the one El lier um
while we need to be prepared in in the
event that something like that were to
happen again I think we need to
recognize also that um many of the
programs that we certify are um are very
high quality and have um have have have
changed lives for the better as as many
questions Perez thank you Mr chair for
allowing me and thank you for taking my
question can I ask you again do you just
say the three weeks it seems like a long
time but it's not a long time for
children to to go through this
process I just I just kind of like want
like no I mean time Horizons are tricky
I mean is is uh just as sitting in a
windowless emergency room uh as a child
who's boarding in the emergency
department is a 3 weeks is is too long
um we would argue that we need to take
decisive action um also in situations
when risks are presented so um you know
we've we feel confident that we got
those youth back safely that we designed
plans of care so that they were um
returned returned safely returned as
promptly as was necessary um we are
constant is everything in the
residential system and in those
emergency situations perfect absolutely
not that's why we've been working both
before the bledo incident and
subsequently to analyze everything
that's gone on and how we can improve
and I would State again that that's why
these sometimes more than monthly it
felt like for a while weekly meetings um
with the office of the child advocate to
get their input on our Improvement as
well as our ability to coordinate so
that when they make a visit or when the
dcyf team makes a visit or when the bcbh
team makes a visit we're exchanging
information so that in the future um
regardless of how we want to judge three
or four weeks that we're able to be even
tighter with our process to coordinate
safe thank you Mr CH thank you Mr
chairman for allowing me to have this
question and thank you for taking my
question before these children were sent
to bledo was anybody sent to the
facility to check out the facility to
see how it was operational and interview
any of the children that were already
living there so at that time we were
still operating as were most States
under covid era protocols that allowed
virtual visits in place of in-person
visits obviously that has now changed um
and again I want to emphasize that for
those particularly um vulnerable DCF
Affiliated youth who have experienced um
abuse and neglect and many other
adversities in their life we're still
making monthly visits um for those youth
even during Co so during the covid uh oh
thank you follow up so even during the
covid
times people were able to visit
facilities by wearing masks if they you
know to protect themselves so I don't
understand
hand so during covid we did things like
virtual tours and virtual visits with
clinicians for the certification process
with regard to individual youth they
were accompanied by dcyf staff and that
those staff were responsible for looking
at the facilities when they arrived with
the youth and ensuring they were leaving
them in a safe environment so there were
eyes on the facility by DHHS staff when
facility followup
chair I don't want to compare this to
looking for a home but if you look at an
ML MLS listing and you're looking
through the pictures and then you go to
the house to look at the house it looks
totally different than what a virtual T
question in there somewhere right so I
don't
the reasoning to
not other than
covid what was the justification to just
rely on a virtual
tour as being a
sufficient way to judge a
facility so I think knowing the history
in the context around certification and
it moving to the division of Behavioral
Health is important prior to a few years
ago and right before the pandemic The
Bureau for children's Behavioral Health
did not exist all of these functions
existed with in DCF and that was the
regular practice that the DCF workers
would be doing that work as they went
down there in order to enhance the
oversight of residential treatment and
move our system forward we now have a
residential unit within the Bureau for
children's Behavioral Health that has
taken on those functions um but that
really was the norm previous
that DCF in partnership with the DCF
workers the did certification were the
individuals responsible for those
on-site visits when we were using new
providers um additionally we do confer
with our neighboring states and the
licensing entity in the home state to
talk to the people who have been on site
input eyes on the facility it's also
worth noting even prior to covid um
visits by DCF were occurring quarterly
um we increased that to to monthly and
and again now that we're it's
it's in a strange way the world has
gotten in some ways so back to normal
that even certain things I think of um
relatives um who passed away who we had
to say goodbye to over iPads there were
realities during covid that were very
different and we are grateful that we're
now back to a place where um those who
are most vulnerable Among Us are um
absolutely need to be seen with eyes on
so we share your concern in that
regard thank you representative
Deon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question um you said it can take up to
120 days to get a contract
signed do want said in the ballpark I
think that's best case thank you yeah
followup follow up sure thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking a followup
how long does it take to
certify
so certification is entirely voluntary
it's up to the engagement of the
provider if it's a company that we've
done business with before or um someone
that has a very um efficient business
office we can get them through the
certification process in less than a
month including booking travel to
another facility I have um Paula R who
does the certification visits for us
with me today on Monday she's going down
to Virginia to do the last step and look
at a new facility for a youth who we
cannot meet the needs anywhere else so
we can do it under a month if they are
able to get us all of their business
documentation their insurance
documentation their licensing
documentation a lot of it is the going
back and forth to say you didn't get
what we need under the rules and walking
them through and really helping support
them and some of the programs really
need a lot of support and other programs
are are very quick to respond and
provide all of it but we'll process it
as soon as we have everything thank you
one more sure
thank you Mr chairman one more question
please um you stated that you do monthly
visits now in my question to you is do
you notify these facilities that you're
coming or are they
spot surprise visits so it can be a mix
of both um and in fact even in the bledo
situation once the um issue had risen to
my level in the commissioner's office I
actually did order that a team be
assembled to do un announced visit it
turned out we ended up picking up the
kids even sooner so there wasn't um that
that step did not occur because we made
the ultimate decision that we just
needed to get them but that was an
example of where we have the authority
to do unannounced visits at any time and
we do that locally too as part of our um
performance Improvement uh process thank
you kindly further questions um I have
uh representative giit thank you Mr
chairman um just a uh another question
about the S the uh Contracting
process my the the takeaway that I've
and maybe please correct me if I'm wrong
this is the basis of my question um is
it that a certification is more for like
a standardized care plan and Contracting
is for like a specific individual um who
just needs you know a a very tailored
care plan or is that not the case yeah
I'll take a first I'll take a First Step
at that so I would think of Contracting
as sort of like a when you're building a
system of um programs that you rely on
again I want to emphasize that for 99%
of our programs they're going through a
contracted entity that we work with
closely we we know these direct I mean
these are 99% of the kids served in
residential treatment are done uh
through a very closely connected network
of regional providers so um it's worth
it if you will to put in all that time
and negotiation and relationship
building to really craft a contract that
makes sense since they are going to be
taking many children and many many
dollarss right um and so it makes sense
to go through through that elaborate
process in these urgent cases where we
need to get a youth into a specialized
program that is not part of that current
offering that's the situation in which
again still require that high burden of
um uh or that high bar from the
certification but we might need to do a
one-off and not wait for the
bureaucratic um you know slowness of the
Contracting process to play out okay
followup followup sure so so in other
words
maybe both entities would be appropriate
that that we contract some but we just
certify some absolutely and most of this
bill um helps inform and strengthen the
the process so that we're able you know
with um the blessing and the the passage
of this bill to to even strengthen our
contracted oversight stronger and again
that's why I sort of struggle with the
the sense of division here because so
much we're in agreement with we're
working together to to take what is
already a strong program again a few
years ago there was no Contracting
process rates were not as nearly as
strong as they are um under our current
budget so much has gone on not only to
strengthen Residential Treatment but to
dramatically reduce the number of Youth
served this is the lowest number we've
never had four kids being served out of
our region um these n the success of our
children's system of care work is um is
a it's considered a model nationally so
what we're talking about is strength in
that contracted model while at the same
time offering that occasional bit of
flexibility when we need it um for kids
who's uh who's for which there's not a
program within our contracted menu to
serve
them thank you for allowing me to take
this ask this question on the contract
um if the contract it's a it's 120 day
process at best okay and if they go
through all the steps of developing this
contract let's say it doesn't get
approved does it leave the facility wide
open for not being paid and opening us
ramifications I think that would be
arguable but the certification rules are
certification for payment and if they
comply with the certification for
payment rules the administrative rules
have the force and effective law and we
would be bound to pay them under the
certification
rules any further questions seeing none
uh with respect to the reallocation of
money saved uh are you okay with the
Money Follows a
child is there is there an identifier of
the money following the child I think
that would be extremely complicated they
don't have a certain dollar amount
allocated that would be unspent we pay
bills as they come in we try to be as
responsible as possible but there would
not be for example a budget that's
approved for the Youth and money set
aside from the youth that then would be
moved somewhere else it's more on a
system level of whether or not we're
spending that amount on residential
treatment or not okay because I I just
think it's important to find locations
in the
community um that the money is already
there and we don't have to go through
the process of getting more money um so
any further questions
see you none thank you thank you uh now
I don't know if there's any questions
for Mr Fletcher or we have a few uh DHHS
Representatives here um are there any
questions specific
to uh Mr Moore uh Kaja Fox Jeff Fletcher
Susan
larby uh representative Mr fleser could
you could you come
just identify yourself for a record sure
thank you Jeff fler DCF DCF director
great uh representative uh dmon thank
you Mr chairman um just a couple of
quick questions if you don't mind sir
thank you for taking my question thank
you for coming here I know how busy you
are um you and I have spoken in in
various committees in the past and um
you spoke about the fact that one of
your goals is to uh keep all kids in
state is that correct that would be a
goal follow up sure where are
we um we have um about 81 kids still out
of
state about 250 in
state and the region as was stated
before we went from 15 kids out of
um one more question sure one more I'm
not sure if you're the one to ask this
question to and um if you can't answer
that's okay um in order to make sure
that these facilities are safe for these
kids optimally how many inspectors do
you think we
need yeah that uh we only have three
yeah and that would be with bcbh not
with DCF but in but we are responsible
for visiting monthly so we do have
probation officers and cpsws going down
visiting kids face to face on a monthly
basis in all of our outer State
facilities thank you very much thank you
for other questions uh representative
FL thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question are the people that
do visit these children uh know have met
the children beforehand and know what's
going on with the case because as we
know children that see a familiar face
or know a familiar name coming to them
they tend to be a little bit more
welcoming to talk to that person cuz a
lot of kids it's hard especially in
those situations it's hard for them to
trust someone to talk to especially
about situations like down in the
facility there um to open up about those
situations yes good question that would
be our preference um but through
scheduling you know to send someone down
to Florida or Texas or Arkansas um at a
moment's notice uh it's difficult
there's people want to leave Etc so it's
not always possible on the other hand to
have people going down objectively who
may not know the kid but go in with a
different set of eyes and and meet the
child and see the facility is also has
some benefit to it but our preference
would be to have the actual worker go
down and see their kids
for other questions um I have one uh
with respect to uh finance and I like
the emergency we had in
blo uh you needed Appropriations to look
for
other um alternatives for these children
uh is that identified so if the children
are pulled from out of state that's at a
six7 8,000 how much do it cost to put
somebody out of the region yeah um the
rates vary with different facilities
from five to 10 five to 10 thousand uh a
month a month maybe if you're lucky okay
yeah yeah they're very they're very
expensive the the out of state
facilities are usually more expensive
than in state okay uh so would you
identify that funding for
Alternatives well yeah we we currently
have existing uh we have 260 kids in
state now we have facilities that have
some opening so they would move into
that so in this case with bledo they
moved into another existing quality um
facility um but and we're also building
Alternatives as we speak Community Based
current appropriation right so they
don't have to go to a facility they can
stay forced home kin or with birth
families with a lot of support great
super any further questions see none
thank thank you thank
you um I have two more cards here and
Stevens
morning good morning chairman long
members of the committee my name is
Holly Stevens and I'm the director of
public policy at Nami New Hampshire the
National Alliance on Mental Illness Nami
New Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of Nami New Hampshire I'm here today to
speak in favor of house bill
1573 which you've heard a lot about so
I'm only going to be um brief in my
testimony uh this morning um in
September of 2022 there were
1,169 New Hampshire youth um that were
placed with other family members in
foster homes or in group or residential
facilities which is a staggering number
um you heard that there's about four 440
in residential placement there's another
approximately um at least in 2022 800
that were placed in um other placements
outside of the the home um research has
found that compared with siblings who
remained at the home children placed out
of home have an increased risk of
violence antisocial Behavior low
education common psychiatric disorders
depression premature mortality by either
suicide or injury in adulthood um it's
further found that a foster home is
better than an institution and that
having as you've heard only one and only
stable placement is important for a
child's stability and well-being into
adulthood um we know that children have
much better Developmental and mental
health outcomes when treatment is
provided as close to their family and
community of origin as possible where
the family connections can be preserved
um we are in support of house bill 1573
as it revises the criteria for out of
home placements for children and
increases the oversight and
certification criteria for out ofate
Residential Treatment
programs however um we do have a couple
of concerns with the bill um the first
being um the requirement that no
children be placed outside of New
England um as you've heard we've got now
four children that are outside of New
England um and we do believe that due to
Staffing short staffing placement
shortages as well as certain Specialized
Care that a child may need that there
should be an exception in the bill for
children um when there is no placement
that can be found quickly um for a child
who may maybe in an emergency room and
or if you have a child who is needs
Specialized Care and that Specialized
Care cannot be provided within New
England that there should be exceptions
made for those children um additionally
you've heard a lot about um
certification versus Contracting um Nami
New Hampshire is an organization who has
contracted with the state and we can um
let the committee know that from our own
experience that Contracting with DHHS in
the state can be very cumbersome and
time consuming and as a result could
lead to the delay in care for youth um
so we do have concerns about the
Contracting Provisions um because um we
have seen that it usually takes a lot
more than 120 days to get a contract in
place and therefore there could be
delays in the care of children in in our
state for the one-offs that you've heard
who need to go to um specialized out of
state placements um not I mean New
Hampshire it's in support of um House
Bill 1573 while urging amendments
allowing for exceptions to the
Restriction that no child be placed
outside of New England and eliminating
the Contracting process um that has been
discussed and with that I will take any
questions that the committee may have
thank you any
questions see none thank you oh I'm
sorry did you have a question
representative
kab okay we're good thank you thank you
Gilbert good morning representative long
thank you for having me
today I just want to go ahead and recap
some of the testimony that you heard
today from both the department and
OCA uh the department went ahead and HD
it right on the head uh with their lip
service that we're expecting the
department to govern themselves uh
something that they're already failing
at doing um so with this I do support
the bill uh I do believe that there is a
need for this additional oversight I I
do not believe that the department
should be overseeing themselves uh they
do have that bureaucracy uh Gap there
that is causing a
extreme amount of time and delay with
regards to these
children um I would perpetually say that
oca's uh rendition of what they're
requesting is 100% valid and the lip
service from the Department uh is just
that lip service um we'll go ahead and
you know just give you a real sense of a
real life situation that's occurring uh
residential
not so out out of out of out of home
that that is correct you oh that is
correct child this place out of my child
is placed in a New Hampshire contracted
facility okay at this current juncture
go ahead I I I I will just say that my
child left the facility yet again last
night uh this is a repeating occurrence
that our facility ities are not having
the oversight from both the department
uh and from
DCF um from Behavioral Health and DCF um
we've been requesting for over a year
for my child to be removed from the
residential facility that they are in
currently the child has been having sex
on the unit in this residential facility
with the lack of oversight and
accommodations to ensure that these
children are being properly
supervised um my child has left multiple
times with the facility not even
recognizing or knowing that they're gone
for multiple
hours um this is a lower secure facility
so understandably but the facility
themselves recognizes that they have a
severe crisis with Staffing and the
department is not addressing that to
ensure that we're addressing and not
sending additional more children in
there to be harmed the the Staffing
level of this particular facility for my
knowledge or belief is around 30 to 40
um and we're continually going ahead and
you know keeping that facility at that
maximum capacity really uh when they
cannot support that number of children
um all the parties behind me are well
aware of this uh the department spoke uh
lip service regarding my particular
child in their
testimony um so I really feel that there
is some things that need to be done here
and we're going to keep driving this
home for everybody very good thank you
any questions for Mr
Gilbert representative
Panic thank you for allowing me to take
this qu ask this question representative
long Jamon long um and thank you for
taking my
question um you said that no one
oversees
DHHS uh doesn't the department have
oversight through the D HHS uh oversight
committee so I have attempted to reach
out to them and I was strictly and
strongly uh protested by the former
director and attorney Baker uh when I
attempted to go forward saying that they
were not going to allow me to speak
committee okay thank you thank you Mr
Gober uh just just uh one other question
for whomever may be able to answer it uh
is is there an estimated time of stay in
these
uh uh and these out of home
residential is is there an average is
there an average or it's not or you
average you know is it a year is it six
it um so don't have that information at
my fingertips I will say that the state
vary our commitment is to make these
episodic therapeutic episodes of care so
they need to be um always under the
clinical um appropriate clinical
supervision while regularly being
reassessed through our comprehensive um
assessment process to ensure that the
youth AR better served in another
setting so I don't have an an I don't I
don't even know that we track that um
but what we can say is that our
commitment toward reform that we
continue to work with Advocates with a
child advocate on Etc is for these to be
um uh again to avoid void Residential
Treatment whenever necessary when it is
utilized to ensure that that is a um
episode I can speak to level five
because we just opened our first prtf at
Hamstead um hospital and the stays there
are um roughly six months um a little in
order to um build skills for return to
the community okay great uh Miss
Sanchez thank you for allowing me to
answer this question um so this is
actually the next step of looking at our
residential care and the use of
residential in the state of New hampsh
for the office of the child advocate so
we're starting to try to dig into that
data we know there are kids that are
languishing in care for multiple years
and so that is an absolutely concern of
ours and that is why it's one of the
focuses of this bill is for it to be
short-term episodic stay of treatment
because that is not happening right now
we have many kids that are lingering in
residential facilities that are ready to
move on very good thank
you having uh no more cards I'll close
the hearing on uh 1573
and uh I'll ask if uh would we be ready
to exec
this any anybody GNA I yeah I'm I'm
clear on contract to to certification
are you
clear any
anybody are we ready
to I'm just wondering are are we
supposed to be looking at the two
amendments and the bill and then
executing on whichever one is best
personally i' think we'd need a little
more time I think I do okay
uh you agree you need a little more time
too yes um just so we can go over the
Amendments kind of more thoughtfully
this this is a lot of information to
take in yeah we just had an hour and a
so all right so uh I guess I guess we'll
wait I guess huh all right very good
thank you Mr chair sure can we move uh
exact possibly toward the end of the day
to give people the opportunity to peruse
the Amendments
submitted and
Reas yeah do we want to or well the
thing is what the consensus this is
going to a second committee uh which
which has to be out so we'll have to
come back well why don't we just take a
simple vote on it if we want to execute
or not okay because I guess I guess
multiple people are are having different
opinions okay those those uh that those
that feel they have enough information
up so three four five six seven 8 N9 10
11 uh so I those those that don't put
your hand up so I can make sure I'm
counting right those that
don't don't you're going to go great
we're going to exact uh Mr uh Mr
chairman um so with that
said I'll open the executive session to
House Bill 1573 FN Mr chairman for a
motion uh chair recognizes uh
representative Pearson for a motion Mr
chairman I move Amendment z uh
[Music]
d427 that is the amendment m m brought
forth by DHHS I move this as ought to
pass okay representative CHR moves
Amendment uh 202
24-42
7h uh seconded by representative D
smon may I speak to my motion and you
may thank you as everyone said as doing
side by sides I agree the uh two
amendments are very similar in fact when
the office of child Advocates Deputy um
uh spoke at some length about what the
court needed to do uh I first got the
impression that that was something that
only their amendments spoke of but in
fact looking at the dhh amendment it's
in there pretty much word for word to
repeat these bills are virtually the
same the only difference has to do with
certification versus contract testimony
was given that this is only
1% where there are not contracts that
all the others are in
contracts and uh testimony was given
that uh 120 days to hop through all of
these hopes is
uh a great thing if it happens
and that flexibility is needed so I
believe that the DHHS amendment gives us
99% of what everybody wants but on the
one issue of
Contracting as my opinion
DHHS amendment is the better
one very good uh the I mean the only the
only the only thing that's not in this
amendment that I'm interested in but it
appears that we may not be able to track
it is the uh money following a child I
think it's important because if we're
saving money the state has has a
tendency to save money uh and my goal
would be to have that money going to the
child uh in some other alternative and
I'd like that identified uh but it my
understanding is it's really not
identified evidently there's a uh
there's a fund they use for these
alternative
programs uh when it runs out they may
have to go to cover and Council to get
more uh am I in line uh saying okay so
that's that's correct all right um yeah
that that that would be the only issue
uh that I would like to add I wantan to
I want to be assured that the state's
not gaining Revenue by saving money uh
when we need it to go to this child
representative Pearson is it your
experience as it has been in mind that
sometimes at these hearings when we kind
of like
something the department hears that yep
absolutely I see them shaking their head
and it's giving me that warm and fuzzy
feel Sor that's
inappropriate yeah no that'd be good
okay uh yeah so I I
uh I'm I'm clear within I'm I'm clear on
the certification and the contract and
it appears to me the contract is a
little more complicated and a little
more holds back the child
um and I wasn't clear as to the
advantage
of you know uh I I am clear on the
accountability aspect uh that
accountability needs to be there whether
it's less than 1% or whether it's one
child that accountability needs to be
there uh you know and we need to follow
up with that uh any further discussion
representative Perez
yeah I I just wanted to say that um my
concern is like I want to make sure that
these kids don't H to wa so long in
order for something to happen and that's
the only that's the only concern that I
have because from what I hear from both
testimonies um it seems to one is like
very concerned about the timing how much
time that the kids has to waigh in order
to get out of that
situation and that's the only concern
that I do have time time time we should
not be putting these kids to go through
weeks and weeks and weeks of waiting if
it's something like this happen again I
just want to make sure that these kids
don't has to wait so long and suffer Al
we're responsible for these kids and we
should make things happen
quickly thank you it's a good point
further discussion representative Craig
yeah I'm you know
after here I understand the difference
between the contracts and the
certification I just want to make sure
that we're not saying and I understand
the time I mean certainly 672 hours for
those kids to wait after we figured out
they were in an abusive situation is 672
hours too long so um I want to make sure
though that we're not cutting Corners uh
to make you know that we're saying okay
this will be quicker so let's cut this
corner so that we can make this quicker
has to we have to have both you know I I
I would feel better if if I felt like
DHHS was like yes this was this was a a
stop and we should have done this or and
maybe that's a legal reason that they're
not saying anything um but I think there
is more accountability in this amendment
and I think that's fine but it's
certainly something that I would be
continuing to watch very closely because
I to make sure that this is
enough any further
discussion
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman uh I'm I'm just wondering if
the finance department would be able to
is this going to finance committee after
this so they might be able to address
your issue about uh appropriating the
funds if they're not
[Music]
used maybe we could just send them an
email okay thank
discussion okay seeing none
uh I'll ask the clerk to call a rooll on
Amendment 20
24-42
7h chairman Pearson
yes Vice chairman long
yes representative deimon yes
representative Bickford yes
representative katab yes representative
mcmah yes representative ball yes
representative
Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative
Gman yes representative LC
yes representative patrio is not here
representative
Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative
Molton yes representative Raymond yes 15
yay zero
Nays
and okay so the amendment one absent the
uh the amendment passes 15 to nothing
I'll recognize uh representative Pearson
motion thank you Mr chairman I move on
House Bill
1573 as amended by
0427 are to pass to pass as amended
second second by representative Perez uh
I want to thank uh representative
Pearson and all the Coes sponsors on
working on this this is very Progressive
it it needs to happen I appreciate it
and Mr chairman the neat thing about it
is is if we find that there's a little
place that isn't quite working as hoped
we're all back next
year yeah you got
it uh well some of this are back next
uh on a motion of ought to pass as
amended House Bill 1573 if the clerk
rooll
representative I'm sorry chairman
Pearson yes Vice chairman long yes
representative deimon yes representative
Bickford
yes uh representative katab yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative grman yes representative
LC
yes representative patrino is not here
representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Molton yes representative
zero okay great thank you everybody and
Thursday you may all come back in 10
minutes please this is
break we have a lot of work to do and
ready thank you for what you
awesome
you did it you did it so
much yeah I know that's really sad and
human beings kid oh it does oh it does
job thanks
Pat
yeah
want
no
for
possible
s
for
back
down
there
wrist
I'm starting with a couple of items of
bad news uh representative l no longer
has a Girl Scout Troop so we'll have to
elsewhere
no longer have a quorum opening
executive session on House Bill 1180 n
criteria for reporting child support
delinquencies to the feds and you
remember that was representative uh
Spain Bill and uh the chair
recognizes uh representative sidal back
lit is always thank you thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to introduce uh the
amendment to House Bill 1189 which is
H and do we have it yes we do
it was handed out pile okay the pile of
stuff read his and would you you um you
are moving Amendment 0186 H moved by
representative sidel and do I have a
Democrat who might like to um
agree
or Socialist Workers Party of America or
somebody else
anybody who is
deimon got it can I do with my pen thank
you all right take a minute to read
through
it
and when you're ready representative
sidel would you care to discuss what the
amendment does in light of the hearing
to improve the
Bill thank you Mr chairman um this what
this is for is to address the concerns
that we had in committee um would the
mic be closer to you please
sorry thank you what you're welcome
thank you
um one giving ample notice to oore um of
the Department's intent to report um we
had in testimony that they never
received any um previous warning and was
reported to the passport denial program
um having their passport denied without
them being in the correct aage amount um
at the threshold of the federal
government uh of that program um it also
requires DHS DHHS to submit the
individual obligor pay frequency into
the department s software to avoid a
reage triggers of unnecessary reporting
discussion representative
grman thank you Mr chairman um
so this would be introducing a a new
automated system is that a a new system
I my question is this a new system being
added or according to the woman that was
here I think her first name was Lily
with DHHS she said their system was
capable of doing that of breaking it
down and she believe that that it was at
some individual
cases and is there a cost associated
with the update not that that they
presented she said this bill will have
no impact on DHHS yes
minute Mr chair do you or does anyone
know if this was run by uh the
department child support department oh
it was the
anybody
well can we ask or you can ask the folks
there anybody know I may you may so U Mr
chairman and Committee just looking at
my notes Here we had a uh lady from
child support services at Lisa
dekowski and she made a statement that
said um they already maintain an
automated system that would be able to
respond to to to what is being requested
here so so that the comment was a
positive one yeah I well the 10 days is
if that's enough time for one thing um
but she's right here with us so I didn't
know but it would be okay to
inquire if we've got a good good
Amendment here that works for them works
with
them not to Mr
chair um I'm asking representative
Williams H yeah I keep insulting you I'm
sorry um counselor lawyer
Esquire
yeah yes yes yes you're not paid by the
word
yes right here
joh you see how quickly we regenerate
into chaos now that I'm back in the
chair
thank
B
please what was the question right right
what's the question she's about to
answer it and it will be better if she
knows the question thank you Mr chairman
uh how does this work out for your
department um and like the 10 days that
sort of thing is it are there any
problems whether it's going to be a
smooth transition or does it and you
know does it work for you I would have a
a concern with the 10 days only in that
I'm not sure it gives the uh the obligor
time to respond and that if we send
something out and we have and in 10 days
we're going to report them
that by the time we do something through
the
mail to get them to be able to respond
and I don't that would be a a burden on
them so I think a longer time would be
good um the other issue we have is in
par paragraph B that's all new
um and there's definitely going to be
some uh changes to our system that are
going to be that are going to be needed
we did not do previously do a fiscal
note for this for this for this bill
representative long thank you Mr
chairman uh the bill takes effect in 60
days uh so that's problematic I'm
assuming that is also definitely
you representative Grossman thank you Mr
chairman so seeing this amendment now do
you think there would be need to be a
fiscal note attached to this
upgrade
you we Che yes one more
followup
um is this an issue that comes up often
so for our committee we've only seen
this issue come up before with one case
I'm just curious if this is an issue
that you see
happen more than
once the different touch
points where these issues are brought
up we give a a lot of information to to
the obligor who come come to our program
when they when they first get get signed
up they get a lot of information about
wage assignment and about all the
different kinds of collection then they
they get a notice of debt once they they
get to a certain amount and that talks
about all the different kinds of
enforcement that can go against them and
then there's what's called a Pawn's
notice which I'm sure stands for
something um and that deals with
offset so notice is a big is generally a
big thing in in child support and notice
better representative
Panic um I'd like an upgrade on your
next door neighbor here I must
say I'd like to respond to um
representative grman if I recall from uh
Spain's original testimony I think he
said there was something like 400 cases
that had that problem if I my
else before I call the question I just
wonder going to ask the uh committee if
you really think that with the amendment
it's good to go and they'll get it done
as they get it done and you know takes
effect in 60 days 60 days after the
house approves it the Senate approves it
and the governor signs it um because if
we are going to um delay and ask for
another amendment I'm not sure we can
get it in under the wire so are we good
to go
representative long thank you Mr
chairman uh so if I remember
testimony um there was not a notice
given to representative Spain that was
one
issue uh I don't believe that was
400 people my understanding is that it's
a uh was it $2500 or
$5,000 with respect to passports 2500
um so I I mean is that possible that I
would be in a RAR rage for $10 and my
passport would be
withheld from the feds because they
don't know because your report just says
I'm in a RAR it doesn't say $10 or
$1,000 or
$2500 no because our system only reports
them if they're over the
amount right so the automated system
over
reports when they're over the
$2500 to the
fets okay and how just we cannot discuss
the details of of Mr Spain's case he he
did right he did but they can't okay um
okay I'm I'm fine thanks representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson if I
recall the testimony it was that you
report when it's over 2500 but you do
not take it off the list until it's zero
so in other words it can REM remain on
there even if it's only $5 is that
correct that's
you I sure yeah so originally it was
over $2,500 correct okay so if it if
once it's 25 over $2,500 it gets
reported okay and then it doesn't it
doesn't fluctuate back and forth if you
go back and forth over and under and
over and under it's there until it goes
to zero okay thank
you representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman so as I'm reading both the bill
and and the amendment I don't see
anything in this language that would
change someone who hasn't completely
gotten down to Zero from having to still
work with with the passport office to
fix that nothing in this changes that
okay I saw I thought I saw another
hand I did representative
ball thank you chairman
Pearson I think that what it does say if
I'm reading this that you would not
continue to report it if it doesn't meet
the federal threshold so in other words
once it's under the $2500 should be
removed or maybe I just I'm reading it
very quickly I'm sorry I'm trying to do
correctly I I suppose it could be read
that way that is not the way that is not
the way we read it as the the reporting
the to the to the federal government
government is that's the way that the
federal government does it this is
that's not something that we've made up
that says we're just going to keep
reporting it even if it goes below
that's how the system
works followup if I recall in testimony
um wasn't isn't this a situation where
if you're getting paid bi-weekly half
the year you're always going to be in a
up
because it's it's divided into 52
payments so at every other week you're
going to be behind if I'm I'm sorry I'm
just trying to recall what
that sometimes it can be possible but
somebody would have to have a very large
order to be $2,500 behind every other
week will they followup followup isn't
it possible that some people have very
large
orders it it it is and in cases like
that where we see that that would be
happening we can exempt a case from from
being reported automatically so that we
don't so that we don't hit that thank
you representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking our
questions today so just to recap I I
just want to make sure because this is a
bill that we've kind of been back and
forth on a couple times if someone has
like say they have this thing where it's
bi-weekly but they get paid or they It's
weekly but they get paid bi-weekly
there's a way that they can from what
you said before that that can be
adjusted like it's not just you guys
aren't set in stone like you have to be
by-weekly so there's a way for somebody
to have personal responsibility to make
sure that they're not falling into rears
by changing that schedule or by working
on that schedule is that
correct our systems can take into
account when somebody gets paid the
money's coming in weekly and then
depending on how the child support is
ordered it can be a monthly amount it
could be a bi-weekly that type of thing
okay so it'll acrew
bi-weekly it'll money comes in monthly
and then of course somebody changes and
it that that changes again but the order
acrel stays the same with the court
order until it changes okay but it's not
like they're sorry followup followup
it's not that
they're but there's not an inherent like
set up to to fail on this like there's
there's a way that somebody can work
with the system so that they're not
you seeing no further hands uh the
motion before us is on Amendment
0186 moved by representative Sidell and
seconded by representative D Simon and
role welcome back
yes representative long
no representative disimon
yes representative
bfid yes representative katab yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative
sidel yes Representative grman no
representative LC no representative
Patrina will be voting no representative
Perez no representative Greg no
representative Gibbons no representative
828 um I
would you tell me again how you voted I
didn't hear you I'm sorry did you vote
Yes or No I voted no no okay so it is 8
to8 then 8 to8 uh which means it
itself and would somebody care to make a
motion on that bill itself without the
amendment
yeah I'll I'll move
itl representative long
moves itl and the second by Greg long
and I'm
sorry she's Greg is over there I know
what I thought somebody was gonna make
me a seating chart all right
Gman any further
discussion yes
we here representative Bickford
please someone give me some indication
as to why I should either vote yes or no
on this because I those are your only
choices huh those are your only choices
that well if it helps you I'm quoting no
on
ITF well I was looking for an
explanation of the
you have people who are being
denied P thoughts or something that's
beyond their
control due to the reporting current
reporting
situation it's it's
not oh I'm sorry oh my gosh my pet peeve
were you were you talking
no I never said a word
that means you can repeat it what I'm
looking for is probably not am I you
know we got an amendment on so that
means somebody thought there must be
they could do it better with an
amendment or something defective in it
so what is is it that's right about it
or should we just move it to get it to
the Senate so they can these folks over
there can fix
ahead can I may I um representative
Perez I thought she was going to say oh
thank you yeah yeah um the reason that
I'm I'm I'm supporting the itl motion on
this bill is because to be
honest I keep hearing that this
happening to people and there a lot of
people where is the people when we need
them to come and testify where is the
online testified uh testimonies uh to be
honest I if this is a real issue not
just couple of people issue I wish I can
see people coming in and really tell us
you know the real story behind this bill
that's
all
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman um the the feedback that we got
from New Hampshire legal aid said that
they opposed the bill relative to the
criteria uh
for reporting child support
delinquencies to federal agencies
because if passed it would put the state
system out of compliance with Federal
requirements so we don't want to cause
federal representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman so to build
on what uh representative Perez says um
the this seems to be legislating for one
particular case that's the only and it's
the the the the bill um author and I I
struggle to ethically to pass a bill for
one person especially when we heard
testimony from that person multiple
times about multiple different areas
about how how in aars he was first it
was pennies then it was a couple dollars
then it was $5 and we never saw
paperwork to say that this is what it
was we heard Contra you know
contradictory testimony from the office
of Child Support saying No this is how
our syst works we can tell somebody how
much they're in a rear it doesn't we've
looked at the federal guidelines it
doesn't trigger until
$2,500 I mean at the basis we're here
for the kids and to make sure that
they're getting their payments and this
because one person is having an issue I
don't see why we're legislating a bill
person anyone else yes representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson um I
don't think we're respect respectfully I
don't think we're legislating for one
person and I do think we're legislating
for their children if that one person
could not get their passport in order to
go see their children that could be a
case out there I think this is a case
where there's smoke there's fire um if
one person came up who happened to be a
legislator that this happened to so he
knew there was a way of dealing with it
the average person is just going to say
you can't fight City Hall this is the
way you but this is the way things are
um I think that we we fortunate that it
happened to a representative who could
bring it to our attention because I'm
sure that's it's happening to more than
can't anyone
else Panic
what Sandra Panic oh representative see
my I have a nice seating chart now now
all I have to do thank you now all I
have to do is see okay representative
Panic thank you thank you representative
chairman Pearson for allowing me to make
my put my two cents in um if I
recall when representative Spain did his
testimony he was
consistent about it being $5 in the rare
because every time I sat down I write
notes on my paper and I date on the back
of it what was said so I I see the
consistency here uh he was going to go
for a job in Canada he was doing a job
in Canada he could not do that job
because he was not able to fly to that
fly to his job so that hurts his family
you know to I I think a simple software
fix and he did say numerous times there
was over 400 people that he personally
knows
of that were you know affected by this
type of situation and it's a simple fix
a computer fix a software fix that's
it representative long thank you Mr
chairman I'm voting yes on the itl uh
especially where the amendment didn't
pass the amendment would have uh
detailed better
um detailed better this fix uh again uh
when I look at it across the board um
I'm not getting constituents that have
have a complaint and I've spoke to
plenty of them that have been in a rear
Ridge 500 a th000 um the claim was that
they never got a notice uh but they were
alerted by
passport um that their passport had to
be redone because they were in the RAR
now we heard today that in order to get
that notice to the feds they got to be
$2,500 in the
rear
so you know I I don't I don't see where
I don't see where that um yeah I don't
see where that was stating so I I I'm
I'm not sure of where the glitch is but
there may be a glitch somewhere uh and
also there's no fiscal note it's has
testified to today there's going to be a
cost to this um what that cost is um I
don't know um so that that's why I'm I'm
going to vote to uh itail could I ask
the
agency if ever an
investigation was launched as to what
went wrong in the case of this
individual because he got the notice and
yet it he shouldn't have gotten the
notice but he got one so why was there
ever any attempt to find out where the
us uh unfortunately with I can't address
anything that specifically happens in
any particular case without a a waiver
of confidentiality under our
confidentiality
statute
representative katab thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question could you tell us I assume
after seeing this Bell that you would
have researched and looked into to see
if you could find and identify any
potential cases where the person was in
a rears less than
$2500 where something like this may have
happened did you find any such cases I'm
not asking you specifically names or who
they were but did you find any such
cases that existed I did not do any any
research to to that end in that that's
not my role I wouldn't know I would have
to have asked somebody to do it and I
don't believe that we that we looked
um representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um so I don't I'm uncomfortable
with the back and forth um so my
question is regarding changes that this
bill
would create within the child support
department because my notes from last
time is that there is no fiscal note
because there would not this bill would
not change the practice of the
department at all uh were it to pass
which is why my vote was will be
probably itl unless I'm told differently
right now because my note says um that
you take the position you're already in
compliance it's a federally certified
automated system programmed with the
federal guidelines for reporting and you
do include the amount that's sent to the
feds therefore this isn't going to cost
any money because there's literally
nothing that you would do
differently yes that would that was our
analysis when on the original okay has
that changed as of today on the original
okay I'm sorry thank you that was rud of
back anyone
else the motion before
us is itl move by representative long
and seconded by representative
Grossman and uh it is unamended the
motion is
itl if you are for itl you vote Yes if
you're against
itl you'll vote no Mr
clerk chairman Pearson
no representative long yes
Representative disimon
no representative
bfid Representative
katab no representative mcmah
yes representative ball no
representative
Panic no representative Sidell no
representative grman yes representative
LC yes representative patrino will be
voting yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons yes
yes 10
to six the vote is 10
to6 in favor of the motion of itl and
would representative long please write
the committee
report
and the committee chair representing the
committee does not organize the
negative report so of the six people who
voted no one of you please
which one of you would wish to write The
Minority Report Mr chair I see seven
that voted
Bickford McMahon McMahon voted yes thank
you very
much um so I will give about 30 seconds
for those who voted in the negative to
look at each other and decide
I you will do the negative The Minority
Report got it okay and you will do the
majority report the committee report and
so okay
long all right this uh ends this
concludes the um hearing on H Bill
1189 I now uh excuse me the executive
session on 1189 this now opens the
executive session on Bill
one1
and the chair is looking over to
motion thank you Mr chairman um I'd like
to introduce an amendment to House Bill
1111 dfn it is number
and would you please uh uh is there a
that second on
that Amendment okay I saw you first
representative gibons I've just changed
my seating chart to
Gibbons
update representative sidel would you
please speak to the amendment yes thank
you Mr chairman um this uh amendment was
drafted to address the concerns of this
committee um one on lines 24 and 25 it
removes any cival or criminal immunity
from a mandatory reporter who fails to
make a report of suspected child abuse
and neglect and it also adds two new
sections further outlining um the
failure to report as well as reporting
with malice um or intent to
amendment
you need a copy of
245h somewhere it's got a staple in
ites it was with the one the one we just
together anybody have a stray
0245 hey I do
how
about
Mr chair yes um sorry about
that um didn't we do something similar
to this
this term we did said somebody said yes
oh
you and remember what number it
is
okay and what happened to that I mean
are we doing
duplicating well it's been the Senate
already it failed in the Senate it was
last year
yeah okay but this is sufficiently
different apparently that it is allowed
to come in this year yeah right what I
like is if you darn it if you're going
to have a law has some teeth if you say
thou shalt not there's got to be an or
else but I think the amendment is good
in that it is
restrained uh you'll notice on lines 24
and the following nothing shall provide
civil or criminal immunity for a
mandatory reporter who knowingly fails
to make a report as a mandatory reporter
I take that very seriously and I will
urge on the side of caution knowing that
it has to be investigated uh but I
cannot uh publicly speak to those who
may have knowingly failed to do it for
any number of reasons and I like the
teeth in this if you see it and you
should say it you must say it so it's
teeth but it's it's it's teeth within
reason I think representative long thank
you Mr chairman
so uh we're all we're all um uh
so so if I don't know if it's abuse or
neglect I'm not going to report it
because if I report it I may be charged
for uh filing a false report no it'd be
a good faith well that's what I'm
reading here if it's good faith not it's
if it's in good
faith if it's in good faith oh okay so
if I do file a false report all I got to
say is it's in did it in good faith it's
up to right it's up to the department to
figure that out well it's not up to the
department it's up to the court well
whoever does the investigation yeah okay
and I I I just don't see where this
helps with the issue that we have uh
it's still up to the court um I don't I
don't know if those are I don't know how
those are brought forward to the court
uh maybe the other party that's being
charged with abuse let's start at the
middle representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and um thank you representative
long or vice chair long for bringing
that uh example up so when we're looking
at a bill like this um you know and what
we're we're talking about reporting and
we know that the people that take in the
reports have already said please don't
do this because they have a great system
for vetting those that are conscientious
are going to be the ones that are
hesitant those that are that are worried
about you know maybe saying that it's
abuse and it's not abuse those are the
ones that that we're actually going to
make hesitate more with legislation like
this those that are doing this for
malice or doing this to be cruel they
don't care about this kind of
legislation they're doing it anyway
false police reports those are already
against the law we already have you know
measures to help keep this so what all
this kind of legislation does is it make
those makes those that are conscientious
that are thinking about oh my gosh could
I be doing this hesitate not the ones
that are doing this for malice they
don't care anyway they already know that
you can't do
that so your conclusion about the
amendment would be
what um I would not be in support of it
okay representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman um I'm the
one who pointed out during our hearing
um about how a lot of other bills who
have penalties for false reports a lot
of bills a lot of other states have
penalties for false reports um like my
former state of New York have penalties
for mandated reporters who fail to
report and so I appreciated seeing an
amendment that had that my I can't
support it because it says for a
mandatory reporter but New Hampshire has
this weird mandatory reporting law that
no other state in the country has that
says that every adult in New Hampshire
is a mandated reporter if this had the
qualifier that it has later on in the
bill where it says a professional
mandatory reporter so under on page two
under item nine it says any person in
their professional capacity as a
mandated reporter I would feel better
about it because really what the the
point of having a crimal a penalty for
someone failing to report is to get
those doctors and you know School
professionals and other professionals
who should know better who aren't
reporting but this hits you know your
neighbor down the street um and that's
not the intent I don't want the neighbor
down the street who has a genuine
concern about these kids to not call it
in because they're worried that they're
going to get in trouble with the law for
for failing to call it in I also don't
want the neighbor down the street to not
call it in because they think someone's
going to think they're lying like we
want people to call and we want the
experts at the state to do their job so
I can't I I can't support it repr appr
the try though repr representative
Gibbons thank you Mr chairman um my
stepmother is a social worker and uh
I've talked to her extensively about
this subject and she does confirm that
uh there are plenty of false reports um
that are made to that she's in a
different state but regardless um if
they exist in other states they exist
here too um there are plenty of people
that make false reports
and she wishes that her state would
would enact some penalties because it
would
deter uh it would deter the false
reports you're you're right that there
are some people that are malicious
enough to know that uh they might face
consequences and then do it anyway but
the the whole point of creating a law
against false reports is so that you can
convict these people you can't convict
them if there is no law about it um the
other so so first of all false reports
do happen secondly uh we need there to
be some type of consequence for false
reports and you know maybe it's a a
difference of opinion that I have with
some of my colleagues but I don't think
that this would
deter uh regular reporting because if
you're reporting in good faith you don't
have to to know it's not your job to do
the investigation if you're reporting in
good faith then no harm comes to you
it's if you're reporting in bad faith
and the department investigates it and
they find that it was in in bad faith
that's when you can get
convicted um
so that's that's
it representative D
Simon thank you Mr chairman I used an
analogy that happened to me I heard a
neighbor
using horrifying language to their
child I felt it was
abusive I contacted the correct phone
numbers and spoke to a person and said
I'm hearing this abuse going on
continually I don't know if it's illegal
or not but this child in family should
be investigated
blah blah
blah um I did get notified later that
abuse
so a year later I saw the person
specifically hitting the
child called again my point of telling
that and and it was found abusive they
were investigated and they were helped
they were assisted in understanding what
the difference between abuse and and not
abuse was and the family thrived after
that and I was happy my point of saying
this is one of the things that I called
about was
actually I still believe it's abusive
but by law it's not abusive but it
didn't deter me from calling
again and this was long before I was
involved with the
legislature so I I don't see this
affecting people who
legitimately call because they believe
there's abuse but I do see it affecting
disgruntled acquaintance however they're
acquainted to the particular person of
calling and continually giving false
reports and that's why I think that this
is an important
amendment to pass thank
you live long please thank you Mr
chairman So currently you could file
with the court if somebody is
maliciously saying that you're you're
abusing or neglecting your child so this
does nothing to add to that
enforcement uh and what it does do
is as a as a as a you know as a required
reporter we're all required reporters I
I I believe that it'll it'll make people
think uh if this is if this is standing
forward so this does not add more
enforcement this does not fix the
problem if the problem is still going to
happen you're still going to have to go
to court it's not up to the department
to determine whether they were
malicious
representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman so I think
I number one concern here is protecting
children at all costs now I understand
that some people may call in false
reports some people may call whether
they're fearful or not and others may
not call in because they're fearful but
the bottom line is are we concerned with
the convicting individuals for false
reports or are we concerned with
protecting children at all costs and so
the bottom line is let's protect the
children regardless of who's making the
phone call whether the calls are sincere
and well- intended or whether or not
their faults always best to air on the
side of caution thank you professionally
over the years I've known several people
who were the victims of malicious false
reporting and I sure want to protect
them too so our hand this way
representative Panic then thank you
chairman
um on line number 12 through 17 it says
reports made to the to the department
may include the name address and phone
number of the person or persons making
the report so that would be a detriment
cuz right now you can send a report in
you can put a report in and an Anonymous
report and you have nowhere to go if it
seems to if it was a false report if
this person has to leave their name an
address and telephone number that's
going to be a deterrent from them giving
a false
report but if it says may include they
don't have to oh that's the operative
word in that sense so we need to change
this to they shall well this is the
amendment we've got in front of us we
can't change it right now representative
Perez yeah to be hon as this bill
concerns me if someone who is a Survivor
and someone who tried to report many
times and I know people try to report
domestic violent and Sh abuse this is
concerning me when it comes
to victims we not protect them victims
we put them on the eyes of the abusers
just to continue doing what they have
done representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman um another perspective is that
when people make malicious reports it
can separate families if it's pursued um
as though the report if if there if
there if it's pursued as though it's a
real report it can cause harm to the
families
so one can look at the situation as
we're protecting the children if we're
if we're
discouraging false reporting
and and to sorry to circle around to
representative panic's statement um you
can still according to the way this
amendment is written you can still
report anonymously and we do want to
protect that you're encouraged to give
your information so they can Circle back
with you but you still have the right to
be
anonymous representative Bickford thank
you Mr
chairman if I recall correctly I believe
uh attorney counselor etc etc Esquire
Williams came in and spoke to us on this
didn't he on this bill Drake ahead
good and um told us that there wasn't
there was no issue over there at DCF
that's what I understood this would not
go to dcyf but to law enforcement the
good counselor said quote it's a law
enforce because it's being overused
that's the that's the belief it's be
someone's overusing
this by making apparently a lot of phone
calls and apparently not anonymously and
so they're going to be charge it would
have I feel it would have a chilling
effect I I did before um I was a student
of uh Dr uh Mary Stewart guile who used
to be the chairman of this committee and
she insisted that where everyone was a
mandatory uh when we made it that way I
was on the committee at the time that we
shouldn't do this sort of thing and
because I thought the same thing I
thought we should we should do it and
with there not a problem with PCF which
handles this
stuff as being overburdened and
everything I don't think it's necessary
um I don't really see people shouldn't
be a victim of false reporting uh D DCF
comes over knocks on your door and say
can I talk to you and if there's nothing
there it's not a problem so they're not
really a victim of anything if they're
good actors and DC and dcyf is a good
actor too and of course we do believe
that during the hearing representative
McMahon
asked uh director Jeff fer of DCF do we
need this
bill Mr fer said yes we
do I think that was that was during the
hearing sometime John John William came
back and said that was an error yeah I
got right I got Mr flesher and Mr
discussions okay so uh that one ended in
a
tie anyone else representative
Kap so assuming that we're going to take
lunch at some point I know noticed that
rep Raymond mentioned that she liked the
majority of the amendment except she
didn't like the fact that it wasn't
saying that it didn't have if you failed
to report in as a professional
reporter if so perhaps if we're taking
lunch we could ask OLS to make that
change if that would then make her
supportive of
the I Mr chairman if I may respond yes
um that is an issue that I have with the
amendment
um and I appreciated the attempt to
address my question at the at the
hearing
um however I still feel very strongly
that um there are ways of handling
people who are using DCF as a weapon uh
that don't require this type of
legislative solution and I in my
experience and like I said I worked in a
state um as a worker who where there was
a law like this and I've worked here
where there isn't um and in both
cases the majority of the false reports
or using DCF to harass someone is in a
high complect domestic violence
situation and this bill I don't believe
will have any impact on that whatsoever
because in those high conflict domestic
violence situations it's about power and
control and that person is going to
utilize whatever tools they have at
their disposal and I have never seen in
my professional experience anyone
prosecuted for calling too much because
it's impossible to say that a parent
doesn't have a genuine concern about the
safety of their child even when you know
that that parent has a history of
domestic violence and inappropriate
behavior to the other parent you it's I
the only case I've ever seen prosecuted
for for FAL for was a fail to report by
a school guidance counselor I've never
seen anybody part prosecuted in New York
either for calling repeatedly on their
neighbor or calling repeatedly on their
ex um we as a worker you go out and say
listen if you keep this up we are going
to send the police out to talk to you
but that's like the most I've ever seen
have happen so representative
Gibbons thank you Mr chairman um the
other side of that though is that you
were working in another state that had
this law on the books and it there's the
potential that it deterred the that type
of behavior
meaning you didn't see it prosecuted
because people the because the the the
affected we have before us the amendment
0245 it is a replace the entire Bill
kind of amendment if this amendment uh
uh fails then we go back to the original
bill
the amendment 0245 was moved by
representative Sidell and seconded by
representative Gibbons the clerk please
uh call the role on the acceptance of
the
amendment chairman Pearson
yes representative long no
representative
disimon representative
bfid uh ought to pass right so um can
pass I'm a no on that
yeah am thank you no on the amendment
representative katab yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball
yes representative Panic yes
representative Sidell yes Representative
grman no representative LC no
representative Patrina will be voting no
representative Perez
oh she stepped out okay representative
Greg no representative Gibbons yes
representative
passes no I have eight
seven five six seven the amendment
passes by a vote of 8 to 7 and now we
have before us House Bill 1111 as
amended by
0245 and the chair is looking at
representative sidel for
motion thank you Mr chairman kind of in
my own little world something else going
on I will move to I'm sorry no never
mind just uh a motion to uh OTP OTP
h111 by sidel and a
second second is representative D Simon
any further
discussion
so the amendment we just passed is now
the bill but we have to vote it
again
anybody would the clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson yes representative
long no representative Dison yes
Representative bfid no representative
katab yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
Representative grman no representative
l no representative Patrina will be
voting no representative Perez not here
representative Greg no representative
Gibbons yes representative Raymond no 8
to7 8 to7 and would representative sidel
please prepare the committee
report and uh we'll do a Minority Report
doing so there be no
Min okay as you as you wish um this ends
the executive session on House Bill 1111
and we will break until
1:30 those of you who need to write
in doing
today
so
okay
stopped okay let's do this we're going
to do a few things out of order here and
I am now going to open the hearing on um
no I'm not I'm going to open the exact
session on
1266 permitting recordings of open
Family Court
proceedings and the chair is looking at
motion and she's looking for her
button
1266 we're going out of
order welcome listen it's easy confuse
welcome 1266 permitting recordings of
open Family Court
proceedings Chief sponsor is katab I'm
looking at a few of her bills now
because she's seat filling and she's
right here we don't have to spend any
in and in the executive session I'm uh
filling in time here on 2620 2 for the
chair now looks to representative ball
for
motion I'd like to thank you chairman
Pearson I'd like to make a motion to OTP
House Bill
1266 is just should have asked this a
minute ago are there any amendments
floating I didn't see any either so we
skip down to move uh that is
representative ball it is
OTP and do we have a
second
any Dem Want a second demat one a second
nobody wants to Second so okay
representative D
Simon
um representative Ball please speak to
bill this bill will allow the
proceedings um parties to record
proceedings that are in an open um open
anybody remember this goes back to
sometimes the court recordings are cut
off and through some of the work we did
with the special committee on the Family
Division of the Circuit Court we found
out that that um does happen sometimes
because of Machinery okay and uh parties
who are litigating prosay may want to
remember what they actually said in did
previous bills on this were way too
broad in
scope um some of the problems that arose
in previous bills are fixed in line 10
and following electronic recording or
transmission of private communication of
others including bench and sidebar
conferences conferences between Council
conferences between councel and client
are prohibited this is what the judges
said has to be and it makes sense to us
um so this just broadens on behalf of um
many people we heard who were in Family
Court who felt this would be an
advantage the question is can it be done
in such a way that is not disruptive and
um in my opinion the the bill deals with
both of those anybody
else representative
kab thank you Mr chairman I Echo much of
what you just said and I did want to add
that there was a similar bill that was
put in the year before last year and it
passed the house on 20 to0 consent and
then it got over to the Senate and there
was concern about recording of private
sidebar conversations and whatnot so I
did explicitly add that into this bill
just to make sure that there was kind of
and no
other potential things I do want to
point out that when something is open to
the public
the anybody from the public can go in
and get a copy of the reporting these
are hearings that are open up to the
public however as you said we got
comments that sometimes the the
recording equipment was accidentally
being turned off so uh there shouldn't
be any concern about privacy here
because these are open to the public and
anybody can the next day go into the
court and get what the court has
available for recordings this is just
simply making sure that if the court
equipment fails the person has their own
recording that's all thank you thank you
anyone else saw another hand down this
way did I I did representative Raymond
thank you um so I am actually opposed to
this bill um I appreciate that um care
was taken in crafting it for making sure
that this isn't going to violate any
privacy issues that these are already
open hearing so that leaves some of my
concern that I had over the last version
of it that you know I kids deserve
privacy um and so I appreciate that
we're protecting them um my question is
question my concern with the bill is
about um chain of custody it for me
there's one thing to make a recording
for your own private you know personal
recollection you need to refresh your
recollection of what happened you can't
get the recording from court for some
reason um you don't want to pay you have
it however um to introduce a recording
that someone has made on their own
personal recording device with no
history of what happened in an appeal or
something else I think is a slippery
slope where it is not possible to
determine you know what kind of editing
has been done to these recordings um I
also am very sensitive uh to domestic
violence situations and cases where
someone might take their own personal
recording cut in and splice it and on
because it's theirs they can do what
they want on it and post it on social
media and use it to harass or um
otherwise um try to control and exploit
um an ex for whom they they have
contempt and I
just for those two reasons the the chain
of custody issue and the the potential
for domestic violence I just can't
support
it representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman um the the the email that we
received from the New Hampshire
uh um legal
assistance uh says that they are opposed
to the bill because you can already
record the proceeding you just need
prior permission from the court uh so
I'm not sure where this bill is
necessary um and and I can confirm that
it is written on the on the judicial
branch website in the court rules that
you are allowed to to uh record because
I read it on there before with
permission yes okay if that being the
case I I personally am not opposed to
passing a law that just underscores
what's already there I do that across
the ideological Spectrum I tend to be
more as better uh representative katab
you're the prime so how would you answer
that thank you so to respond to both
kind of things that were said one this
this doesn't say that this is admissible
or can otherwise be used in court this
just says that you could make a
recording it doesn't in any way say that
it's admissible or that you can use it
to create transcripts um regarding that
yes you can already do it if you put in
notice in advance but we heard from some
people you know that if something's
going away that they didn't expect it to
go and suddenly in the middle they're
like they're their prosay by themselves
they want to be able to record it just
to for their own I didn't expect this to
happen I I now want a copy and they
didn't for for see needing a copy in
advance so they didn't ask for
permission in advance I just you know if
it's your part if you're part of the
proceeding I just think you should be
able to record it but um in terms of
like the comment on splicing I mean
somebody could do that with the Court's
copy as well so I don't think that this
is going to change either of those
things I think this is just allowing
somebody to have their own personal copy
of of their hearing that they're a part
of Representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman and I do appreciate uh
representative tabs take on it where you
might decide that you need a recording
prior to or sorry after or during your
hearing and so if you lost the
opportunity to uh
record uh sorry to to to request to be
able to record you might still want that
Avenue open um that opens up to my next
question
where New Hampshire uh legal assistance
recognizes this bill raises concerns
about how the Supreme Court will decide
which recording to rely upon for
appealed cases so I wonder if we should
amend this to say that the courts
because this would address not only
Caitlyn's point but also uh
representative uh Raymond's point where
if we're concerned about that editing
might happen and how uh uh evidence
might be tampered with if if multiple
parties can record then we should make a
a caveat saying that only the Court's
recording is admissible for
appeals and so would would we be open to
amending it to put that in
representative
katab thank you for the question thank
you for recognizing me thank you for the
question you know I think
if for some reason the Court's equipment
had failed to pick up something that was
important I think the court you know
there's the court is has the the ability
to decide if something has otherwise
been tampered with or potentially you
know if if again their recording
equipment failed for a certain period of
time I think you can be able to tell a
lot of these things based on the fact
that you know if the hearing you know
opened at 10:1 p.m. and ended at you
know 1 uh at 2:1 p.m. and we only have
49 minutes of recording that obviously
that there was something missing there
you know and I mean there are obviously
laws on the books about falsifying or
submitting false things so I just I
really don't foresee that that
necessarily happening and I think the
court can decide rather to accept the
evidence or not nothing is saying that
this would be accepted or would be
admissible I think that I wouldn't want
to T tie a judge's hands one way or the
other I think the judges can decide
whether or not to accept something and
certainly typically
they're going by transcripts that are
kind of coming out so if somebody
disagrees or says that something's
missing in there and asks the court hey
can you look into this I think there are
plenty of ways of of verifying if a
recording's been tampered with or not I
mean look at CNN going through and Geo
GE locating exactly time and dates of
things that happen
so uh representative
Greg thank you I have a two-part
question is that okay can I just ask for
a followup okay thanks so on the elri
iic recording or transmission of private
communication of others including bench
sidebar conferences so we've already
Unleashed them to be able to record
who's going to monitor the fact that
they're then turning it off if there's
like a sidebar because I mean they're
recording devices now they can pick up
pretty far so so how is that going to
get policed because that's obviously a
big uh who's to say you can't do that
now if indeed it is elicit to do such
how's that happen but you have to have
permission so a lot of times when the
judge is giving permission he knows then
who's recording and he can say you need
to turn that off right now and he can
observe that he or she I shouldn't I
should not there were women judges now
there there are that so
um that's one thing I mean I I I have
great respect for um for this bill I
understand the reasoning we certainly
have heard things I also have a great
respect for our judicial system and the
judge's ability to um mandate over their
own court and they certainly should have
that uh position to be able to make the
decision whether or not somebody should
be able to record because we've seen in
real time somebody record their
proceedings and then use it as a weapon
and post it online that's been that's
been a problem and whether or not the
judge has known that is something else
or but the judge should have the ability
to control their own court room in that
um as far as who you know the behaviors
and that kind of stuff to help keep you
know some kind of control over a very
you know very volatile situations that's
why I will not be supporting this
bill representative
Gibbons okay representative L uh thank
you Mr chairman just with respect to the
uh uh line six the recording devices
used by the Pary does not interfere with
the proceedings is that exclusively on
the
judge do we can we assume that it is
okay
anyone
else representative Bickford thank you
Mr chairman I uh I don't think I have
any problem with the bill because it
pretty much matches what I think goes on
now I'm not sure why we need it but it
is nice to tell people what they can do
sometimes as long as a judge uh can make
the decisions and this bill it doesn't
look like it supersedes anything that
the court already has in place so I I I
don't see any damage by
it that's my Spiel oh and and I I heard
about domestic violence
being uh I aren't those aren't those are
those proceedings uh closed or they
open I thought they were cold but I I
haven't been
lately representative Greg so in a
divorce proceedings that's where you're
going to domestic violence can come up
right that's not a criminal trial so
there can be there many times there are
a lot of manipulations especially within
prosay and stuff with domestic violence
you see that in family courts very very
often and um weaponizing in a particular
happened representative long yeah just
uh for clarification currently uh you
need permission from the judge this bill
says you shall be able to so you don't
need permission from the judge oh really
right is that correct mhm but I thought
the last um it does the last paragraph
cleared that up I thought where have I
it nothing in the section shall prohibit
a party or non-party who is otherwise
authorized by law or court order to
record proceedings from doing
so so doesn't that kind of flip it the
other
way
representative kab I think it's the
judge still has the the discre because
it does say that you know it can't be
interfering with the proceeding which
would be at the discretion of the judge
so I think the Judge would still have
the ability if for whatever reason they
felt that it's interfering with the
proceeding to to be able
person the fact that about 85% of the
litigant in Family Court are
prosay um and if their hearing is
continued and they're wondering what did
I say what did the other side say I
don't know what to look for with the
scrutiny of a lawyer I need to go back
and listen what anybody remember what I
said or what they said this gives that
opportunity uh when we were taking lots
of hearings on Family Court even
allowing for people arguing out of anger
because they lost the case even allowing
that um it just sounded like there were
too many instances where certain judges
really didn't want any recordings done
and that seemed to me a violation of
people's rights that even as I say
discounting a lot of disgruntled people
it sounded like certain one
did not give permission all that often
this gives to me a civil right to the
prosay
litigants representative uh B oh that's
bigford I'm one person behind Gibbons
thank you Mr chairman I remembered what
I was going to ask
um do if I I'm not sure what the answer
is so if anyone does know the answer
please pipe up um when we talk about the
court transcript is that that in writing
or is that the recording the audio
recording I would expect it to be the
writing but I'm not entirely sure
representative kab you you thank you Mr
de um it it is the written transcript
which is authorized to be prepared by
one specific company that the court has
approved to prepare the transcripts and
it's not automatic those are privately
paid if you want to if you want the
transcript you pay for them to generate
the transcript this
company
seeing no further discussion
the motion before us is on Bill House
Bill 1266 FN moved ought to pass by
representative Ball seconded by
representative D Simone would the clerk
please call the
role chairman Pearson yes representative
long representative
disimon representative ative bfid yes
representative katab yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes Representative grman no
representative LC you don't see
present the clerk will vote
no representative Perez I do not see her
representative Greg
Gibbons this is a tough one for me I'm
GNA say
no we have
six moved this oh I have it down here
yeah B I'm I'm skipping a line and if
you would have the representative ball
if you would have the blurb for the
brilliant next we goes to be okay next
uh this uh concludes the exec session on
1266 opening the exec session on 1263
again because the prime sponsor had
happens to be here in a seat filling
capacity parenting coordinators in high
1263 and uh do we have amendments I do
we have a I do and that would be
476 uh 476 yes is there another
amendment thought I heard another
amendment floating
around
yeah there's only one I believe only one
okay just just want to make sure because
we only get one bite at this um
representative long for a
number
House Bill 1263 Amendment
0476 does anybody have not
you so representative long for motion on
the
amendment the amendment
on come on guys settle
uh thank you Mr chairman I move
Amendment
04768 a the
pass anybody need one put your hand up
extras and who would second this
amendment anybody uh yeah
and representative long would you please
discuss the amendment I will thank you
uh thank you Mr chairman the the um the
two differences is one with respect to
the training it adds uh domestic
violence to that
training and that's found on uh line
five of the amendment okay and where is
that in the where does that slot in in
the bill in the bill
um why line 18
1263 I already found it it slots in at
line 18 line 18 in the bill has
techniques mediation and legal issues
and line five of the amendment adds
domestic
violence okay
yeah and the other change and the other
uh
the other change is with respect to the
um if the parties object to the
appointment actually line 13 on the
amendment if the party objects to the
appointment the court shall appoint a
different person within seven days after
the date of the party's
objection and uh in the original
which it takes out the words or confirms
correct confirm
yeah those those are the only two
changes to the original bill I recall
these were the two issues we had when we
heard the bill yeah originally all right
yeah yeah the part of Representative
long is being played by um
yeah any other questions uh for the vice
this yes representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman um I just
have a question what happens cuz my
understanding is there's
one one uh person who does this right
now in the state um so what happens if
there's not a second person or do we
pass the law first and then hope that
courts then now create these positions I
I guess that's I'm just
worried because I I like the idea I
really like the idea I just do we need
infrastructure first or we do the law
first and then infrastructure comes
after well sometimes the law nudges
people to put in place what the law
tells
so
okay yeah so I mean I can respond to
that if you please do um so there is one
person in nashwa that we've heard that
is doing this currently our
understanding though in testimony is
that um uh because it's not just
attorneys uh other professionals that
they would step up to do this so that's
the hopes that uh there will
be more circuit courts utilizing this uh
you know we heard in testimony that that
works great in high conflict um
situations um so we're hoping that
professionals will step up to do this
this
mediation okay thank you anyone else
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman um also with there being a
fiscal note attached they could just
they could appropriate funds for for
more uh positions of parenting
coordinators if they needed
believe representative
Greg yes so one of the things in our
special committee that we kind of
listened to and that we've saw we saw
within the courts too was um our Gala
has been a a great resource however one
of the I probably biggest disservices we
did was not funding that anymore because
um we have a lot of our Indigent
families that could really use this now
what this does is not only brings
another aspect where we have other areas
of expertise besides law um and training
to help with um you know helping to get
the parents uh some kind of you know
help um by doing this but also it
provides that maybe the um mediation
fund and such could be used now this
isn't I don't think this is necessarily
a perfect bill but I think it's a great
step in the right direction as far as
helping the families that need it the
most which is why you were a co-sponsor
else seeing no other hands the motion
before us is amendment d0 0476 to House
Bill
1263 uh moved by representative long
seconded by representative Greg who
thinks it's pretty good and when the
clerk is ready please call the rooll
chairman Pearson yes representative long
yes representative disimon
representative bfid representative katab
yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative grman yes representative
LC is not present representative patrino
will vote Yes representative Perez is
not present representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons yes
representative Raymond yes 14 to
zero the chair will now entertain a
amended
he's he's looking for friends kab she
can't she's writing the blurb yeah okay
thank you uh I'll move on to pass otpa
otpa and let's have a a republican can
we why that would be me seconds it and
uh away we go any further discussion
seeing none would the clerk please call
the role on the motion
o2p
OT a to OT
p
a as amended easy for me to say by
0476 um move by long and represent in
second by me please call the RO chairman
Pearson yes representative long yes
representative Dion yes representative
bfid yes representative katab yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative GR ran yes representative
L is not present representative Patrina
will vote Yes representative Perez not
present representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons yes
representative Raymond yes 14 to
zero representative long ay assisted by
representative katab we'll write the
blurb and get that to me shortly please
uh this is a second committee bill so it
doesn't go on
consent that is long
that this closes the executive session
on House Bill
1263 and we now uh open a an executive
106106 on family
parenting time uh I think there's an
amendment floating
04488 bearing the names of Greg and
side
and one or indeed any may move the
amendment actually representative kab
cannot but representative Greg
can yes um I just move to adopt the
amendment well that's what I'm
doing move to adopt the amendment
0448 H for uh one for 106 is this
because you had a Dr Pepper for lunch
it's because I shove my food down so
quick my body's like whoa what are we
doing but you've recovered well doing my
best who'd like to
do and now representative Greg or katab
could tell us what the amendment does
okay so on the original we talked about
um visitation and uh custody or
visitation we changed it all to just
parenting time so you'll see um you know
relative to just parenting time in uh
representative kab's uh conversation
conversations with judge
king um this seemed much more doable as
far as the courts we certainly don't
want to backlog the courts or anything
but we also want these parenting
situations like this to be handled
quickly before children are without
their parents for months so this is only
else
representative oh I I I'll get there
um Gibbons thank you to my friend I
would like to make a
motion oh we do sorry okay never mind
sorry well you might like to but there's
already one on the floor dear okay then
I will you like that one do you yes okay
you can vote Yes in a minute then if you
so the fact that it amends it replaces
section one as I look at the original
Bill section two is just the
of taking effect so that doesn't change
and as I'm trying to do a side by side
here I don't see a whole heck of a lot
of difference between the bill the bill
and its Origins and the amendment could
somebody Point me out a few lines
representative Greg thank you sure so on
um the first main line where it says in
the event of
non-compliance so after the comma after
under this chapter comma instead of
including we Chang that to relative to
and then denying or interfering with and
where it says visitation we've taken
that out and put parenting time um
instead of visitation so also down on
part four letter A A compens A I'm not
even going to pronounce that word right
now so instead of visitation we have
parenting time so custody or visitation
has all been changed to Parenting Time
on line four so this is only dealing
with parenting time okay if we had to
deal with all the others it would be
problem for the courts
and everything else is the same that's
is yeah it looks very nice thank you it
it's cute yeah that's a computer right
you have
there anybody
else representative bigford I think it's
pretty minor but um on line 18
in this case
20 it uh brings back visitation in
rather than parenting
time say what that was something I
pointed
out for the
amendment that's the only thing I see I
don't even see that what do you see tell
me again of the bill or the amendment
compens the amendment 20 on the
amendment L 20 okay it has the word
visitation
both so it should say parenting time
somewhere
if yeah you might be right now this can
be fixed I mean we can go forward how do
we sometimes in enrolled bills or
something I mean isn't there a funny
little process where they can fix their
error
yes
yeah I think um yeah go ahead if we have
a few more bills I might be able to call
Os in the meantime and just ask if they
could fix because we did put it in our
red line for them to fix and they just
missed it so if they could just expedite
fixing it and give it to us if you want
to recess this and go on since we have
other bills can recess this sure um if
you want to give them a call I promise
not to have any fun here while you're
out doing that and tell them to do that
and please then when it's done you got
to muscle it over to the fourth floor
which does something with it and it
comes down here and I've seen that done
minutes in my last committee yes or or
can we submit a floor Amendment it'd be
a no-brain a floor Amendment
right it's going on a regular calendar
because it's an
FN oh yeah that works we could do that
yeah that works you've been here longer
than me
yes yeah let's do the floor Amendment
okay the time I think we'll all agree to
that Flor amend so fly
through happy good let's do that thank
you what a team any further discussion
seeing none the motion before us is the
amendment
0448 to House Bill
10006 moved by representative Greg and
seconded by representative Gman with the
clerk please call the role chairman
Pearson yes representative law yes
representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
cab yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panic yes representative sidel yes
representative Gman yes representative
Le is not present representative Patrina
will vote Yes representative Perez is
not present representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons yes
representative Raymond yes 14 to zero CH
otpa representative Greg I'd like to
make a motion to otpa um House Bill one
uh 106
FN and seconded
by representative
Panic any further discussion motion
before us is ought to pass as
amended House Bill 106 amended by 0448
moved by representative Greg seconded by
representative Panic with the clerk
chairman Pearson yes representative long
yes representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
katab yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative Gman yes representative
patrino will be voting yes
representative Greg yes representative
Gibbons yes representative Raymond yes
and the blurb will be written
by fortified by her Dr Pepper will'll
one all right comes over to me pretty
soon thank you and this concludes the
uh ex ex session on
here I'd like to now um open an
executive session on House Bill
FN um which is establishing a separate
department of children youth and famili
separating dcyf out of D
HHS and the chair moves
itl and I'll speak to my
motion I'll second if you need a second
oh yeah we got to do that don't we who
who was that Raymond yeah okay sorry I
spoke out of turn Mr chairman no that's
fine no that that
that's
good uh it Pearson and Raymond we're
good all right here's the
deal there is simply nothing to be
gained by separating out dcyf from DHHS
and there's a few few things to
lose much of the testimony on this bill
by representative H concerned needed
improvements in DCF such as
accessibility transparency and
accountability and you may recall at
that point I said those are wonderful
things but first they're already working
on them and secondly doesn't matter
whether DCF is independent or not
they're still going to be working on
them so much of his testimony was
wonderful but not really relevant to the
motion of the bill after years of
seeming mismanagement and public
outrage the present director's
predecessor uh Joe ribson was brought in
to clean things up the measures he took
are now being enhanced by the present
director we saw him this morning uh Jeff
fer who hudly acknowledges the needs
mentioned in the testimony for further
improvements and this is demonstrated
ated by his continual work on them this
work will continue and it does not need
dcf's Detachment from DHHS for this to
happen
DCF regularly makes reports to the
children's oversight committee and since
it's under DHHS it periodically makes
reports to the
DHHS oversight committee which I chair
the office of the child advocate
regularly works with DCF the special
committee on the Family Division of the
Circuit Court which I also chair learned
the regularity with which Family Court
intersects with
DCF Casa works with
DCF dcf's director regularly attends
meetings of the governor and councel and
there's
more the director regularly gets calls
on his cell phone and passes them along
to his staff for followup besides such
constituent relations the director
regularly leaves his office to meet with
various stakeholder groups I've asked
and he's named some again this work will
continue and it does not need DCS
Detachment from DHHS for this to happen
the vast majority of other states Place
their
DCFS under their Departments of Health
and Human Services to do the work of
separating out DCF and DHHS would
require a considerable amount of money
for no other apparent gain than just
separating and this is money better
spent in further strengthening and
enhancing the staff at
DCF and make more difficult the
Synergy staff sharing and data system
syncretization now enjoyed by DCF being
in
DHHS and this is true in many other
states and it is true here in New
Hampshire
so that's my motion and
discussion the motion before us is itl
on House Bill 1667 FN moved by Pearson
seconded by Raymond would the clerk
please call the role
chairman Pearson yes representative long
yes representative disimon
representative Bickford yes
representative katab yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative Gman yes
representative L is not present
representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative Perez is not present
representative Greg yes represent
representative Gibbons is not present
representative Raymond yes okay 13 to
zero how many 13 14 14 excuse me uh no
no I no sorry um Gibbons has gone too
zip
um I'm not sure what to do it has a
fiscal
note but it's dead so can it go on
consent what if it's
overturned right it doesn't go anywhere
now
all right any objection to consent if it
can be on
consent seeing none it's on consent
pending approvals of higher Ops there is
a fiscal note on that yeah but it's not
going to a second committee because it
died here I think anyway here's my
blur okay thank
you yeah we'll find that out and if it
has to go on to consent uh off consent
it'll go off consent and this ends the
hearing
on whatever that was 1667 it wasn't a
hearing it was an exec session I'm
opening the exec session now on
1425 on no suspension of a driver's
license in child support enforcement
matters uh Chief sponsor was
representative uh Bernardi
five um does anyone wish to move
this
bill
OTP I move to uh uh OT OTP for this P
this bill okay representative Panic
moves OTP is there a
Bickford
any
microphone uh the sponsor says there's
no amendment huh the sponsor told me
there is no Amendment coming from
well I'm I'm I'm up in the air on the
the bill um and yet you second it it
is well it's just the driver's license
as I recall um I think it's a a very
Draconian move to do such a thing as
that I was here in 19 I think it was
1995 when this passed along with hunting
licenses fishing game you know that sort
of thing um and I've always been uh
opposed to it because we don't collect
money from anybody else in the the same
manner and I always said everything
everybody needs to be on the same level
I I especially know that because I've
lent money to people and had a chase
after it and I really would have loved
to be able to take their driver's
license away from them to get that money
back uh especially when I my daughters
needed
braces uh so I think we should all be in
the same uh playing field as far as
collections it just doesn't make sense
are you arguing against the motion you
just made huh are you arguing against
the motion you just
made okay what did I no you seconded the
OTP and you're arguing itl I'm just want
to
clarify you're not are you for or
against Bill for the bill it's it's
about stopping from taking driver's
reason that's scary I thought I had you
you want me start
over really you would like an amendment
that would Grant you permission to take
people's driver's licenses away who owe
you money I I I do not want driver
license taken because and my reasoning
is because no other place in society
that I know of do we take Driver's away
people for owing somebody money and I'm
saying I would have loved to have that
for myself to collect money from anybody
because you know what I've had kids who
support you know or pay for
braces um on the other hand the my my
question is what is the cost of this and
maybe that's only for um finance
committee I don't know but the feds may
come down on us heavy I don't know when
when Susan bristen spoke to this the
other day she said well there are ways
of doing it softly maybe that was word
uh and but I and that's really what I
expected for an amendment but I really
want to get at least a discussion on it
and maybe get more information so that's
why I agreed to Second
it okay anybody
else representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman so I also
had written down uh I think what what
representative Beckford was referring to
I have a note um from um I think it was
attorney Brens who had spoken to us
that if we pass
this uh it might impact our tan block
grant um because other states have other
states have exceptions but they don't
have nothing right and so I'm concerned
if we pass it without without any kind
of amendment that would give us
exceptions like what other states do
that it might impact our tan of block
grant which will impact significant
funding um for a lot of our programs
including child
support and I know I I Googled and I got
nothing so maybe we could does does
everybody have this Memo from a
committee researcher because it outlines
what other states do and I see some
states have um
don't and I don't know if they're
withheld it is a research project dated
February
1st so Mr chairman yes but I didn't see
on and I did read this I didn't see that
there were any states
that just said a blanket were no longer
going to uh impact the driver's license
what I saw was all of the states have
some impact to Driver's Licenses based
on non-compliance and that if we pass
this we would be the one state that has
no impact on driver's licenses and so
there's no there's no telling what that
will do like there's nothing to compare
it to I mean I don't I don't know what
tanif will do so I guess that's my
question is if we if we Forge ahead and
do this on our own what's tanif going to
do to our funding and I don't know who
answers that question representative
Greg Am I Wrong yes so all 50 states
have something with this and what what
they talked about in here with this is
if we decide that we're going to say
okay we're not going to do this the
drive driver's license there's a certain
federal um government thing that they
require us to do we will not be in line
with that anymore this this is this
could be a big problem all all 50 states
do some driver's license so this is
going to be a
problem um each state is required to
have procedures so there's so it says
right here Department of Health and
Human Services states that there may be
significant fiscal impact to the state
since as a condition of receiving
Federal um is it 4D funds each state is
required to have procedures regarding
the withholding suspension or
restriction of the licenses of
non-custodial parents who owe past uh
due
support what I'm seeing is I flip
through the report is every state seems
to have a stated
reinstatement policy and it is your
statement that uh we don't in this bill
correct yes I'm saying that we would be
completely out of line with all 50 in
the Federal government's requirement if
we no longer did this with driver's
licenses and a reinstatement policy in
the law covers that concern because
there's a way to State it to go about
and get it back we currently have a
reinstatement policy for getting their
driver's licenses they're able to get
their driver's licenses back they
actually we have a a warning period they
have 20 days to file something saying
that they're going to do whatever or pay
a couple dollars we were told over and
over that it's not instant thing they
have time and they're warned and they
have the ability to contact and say
we're going to do this it's for habitual
um uh abusers of the system that
continue to not pay I mean once again
we're looking at the best in interest of
the child in being able to get to get
funds and this is like a last this is
really one of the last resort things
it's not like they're like okay you know
you're you're late one time we're going
to take your license away this is for
people that they've been unable and they
they did say that they've successfully
gotten people to pay you know at least
start paying and then they're able to
have their licenses but it's very rare
that they actually do this my bigger
concern is you know the money from the
federal government and us being out of
line with that I do not see that point I
I'm willing to learn it but I'm looking
through this print out of every state
and every state has the delinquency
Threshold at this point for this many
days we're coming for you and then
everything has a reinstatement policy on
how you get it back right so what do we
not have so Mr chairman yes this bill
would take away the first half of it
which is we would we would no longer
take away licenses because that's what
the bill prohibits us from doing the
bill says you are prohibited from wait
read it taking away so we would no
longer have a reinstatement process
because the you can't take it away and
by getting rid of the taking it away and
the reinstatement process based on the
fiscal note which I have now refreshed
my recollection that would put us out of
compliance with the state plan
requirements as outlined in title 4D of
the Social Security Act and if we are
out of compliance with title 4D of the
Social Security Act the last page of our
paper here says that the total loss of
operational funding for New Hampshire's
child support funding could be 16.9
million in federal fund 1.2 million in
federal child support performance funds
and 1.9 in the federal T of block ground
funding so I was I guess I was hoping to
see in order to pass it an amendment
that would say you know that would
change how we revoke it but if we
entirely remove the requirement to
revoke a license and have a way to get
it back then that is going to cost our
state it looks like
179 $20
million and that to me I just
can't I can't do
it on page two of the uh the memorandum
that we've been looking at here with all
the states it actually has the federal
law here the states authorizing
suspension of licenses so it's actually
on second page the federal law okay is
right yeah so while I I I might
personally have feelings about it I
think I don't feel so strongly that I'm
willing to risk $20 million
no representative
long thank you Mr chairman and and
um what I have a hard time with is is
those that are currently without a
license because of child support they'll
be getting their license back whether
they've been paying up their reage or
not this bill allows them to get their
license
mine anyone
else
the representative bford well I'm
curious as to how much I had asked this
question at the last at the hearing and
uh s uh attorney Susan person gave us
some kind of an indicator and I've
always wondered what would it cost us to
actually
um do something about it and she's
actually the one that brought up the uh
the softer approach on the driver's
license I think i' like more information
on it um I know when we did the mandated
uh wage
assignment um they came up from Boston
actually and told us you do this and
it's 20 million $21 million so not
giving us any more money than we did 20
20 years ago but um sometimes there way
around things
so but anyway I wonder if we can get a
little information from the child
here she was sitting there so
patiently and was doing research while
she was well unfortunately I'm not sure
I have any more information at least on
that area um in that we would definitely
need to speak to
DMV and find out how they deal because
it's sort of a joint thing of we tell
them and then they do that so I don't
know if that's a thing that that they do
we'd have to come up with a new system
to be able to to do that but that is
something a restricted license is one of
the things that is allowed under the
uh under title title
4D procedures under which the state has
and uses in appropriate cases authority
to withhold suspend or to restrict the
use of driver's
licenses we we we're looking if I may
for the cost to the state I mean we know
the full cost could be as much
as $20 million but it uh sometimes they
just take a portion of something you
know anything about that that I don't
that I don't um we haven't had that
goodness we haven't had to deal with
that recently um the
only minor fact that I know is uh at one
point several years ago
Idaho U wasn't going to pass the new um
UA statute and the FED came down on them
hard and quickly was what I was
surprised at so but I have no idea okay
thank you I have in my notes 42 USB 666
a16 yes sir and the note is we have to
suspend various licenses including
driver's
licenses is that a correct citation I
made yes sir and do you have it in front
of you I do of course you do would you
read it
please all right starting at the top in
order to satisfy section 6
542a of this title each state must have
in effect laws requiring the use of the
following procedures consistent with the
section and with regulations of the
secretary to increase the effectiveness
of the program which the state
administers under this part and then
part 16 says authority to withhold or
suspend license we so it requires
procedures under which the state has and
uses authority to withhold suspend or to
restrict the use of driver's licenses
professional and occupational licenses
recreational and supporting licenses of
IND individuals owing overdue support or
failing after receiving appropriate
notice to supply comply with subpoenas
or warrant
related to paternity or child support
proceedings so
there uncle's watching as well as far as
I know only once in my 23 years have we
actually attempted
to take the license of somebody who
refused to show up for paternity testing
and your testimony has been usually the
threat is enough to scare them can be
can be I mean it's the first it's the
first time you you can sort of get them
to talk to you if they're if they're not
paying attention to all of the
send well what do you think
folks withdraw the motion you can
withdraw the motion if you
wish withdraw the motion in the second
that's fine I takes courage to do that
after you've made a motion when new
information is forthcoming so thank you
very much for that now would somebody
motion uh I'll make that oh go ahead you
can do it I'm I oh I guess I'll write
the report then all right one verse
Kumbaya okay the chair recognizes
representative Raymond for a motion of
what uh itl please itl and seconded by
representative Panic All right you get
discussion none with the please call the
rooll the motion is
itl on House Bill 1425
FN chairman Pearson yes to
itl representative long yes
representative disimon representative
bfid yes representative katab
yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes yes representative Sidell yes
representative Gman yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Greg yes representative Raymond yes did
I miss
anyone
okay there we have it 13 to Z 13 to Zer
the motion itl passes representative
Raymond could you come up with a
committee report for me please yes thank
you I'll take that as yes thank you
1425 um it said f n but it failed so
let's any any difficulty with consent if
we may do
it fine if we don't we can't then it
goes away but we at least put our ore in
the water any objection to consent
pending
representative
Wonder oh we can fill something in a
half an hour would you like me to
proceed with your
last all right uh
1564 please and I think everybody's
figured out it is uh very similar to the
1595 so 1595 from representative
Bickford is the prime and
1564 with representative katab as the
prime and uh what we can do is open the
exec session on one of them and uh
somebody make a motion accordingly and
then I can put that into recess open the
the second one and that what that will
give us is a chance to do things in
parallel discuss the relative motions of
both we may decide to kill both pass
both or do one in one so um
representative Bickford would you like
to make a motion on
1595 uh make a motion ought to pass
on
we're doing actually both in a row just
hang in there um motion is auto pass by
bigford um and now we're going to put
that into recess and uh 16
representative kabs um representative
on4 so now we have two bills in play
because they cover the same things
representative Bickford would you speak
please okay that's thank you 15 16 1564
seconded by representative long and
second if there's no second to dies you
don't have to do it but you
may what on
64 uh on 1595 I'm looking for a second
that is your bill oh no one wants to
second
that all right representative Panic
seconds it wow and now now we may
discuss both bills because they're
plowing much the same territory but
there's some different numbers involved
and you and I have gotten emails from
National groups on both sides of this
representative bigford make your case
please well this bill has been asked for
for more than 20 years from the
Department of well from the reviews that
the Department of Child Support Services
has been doing over the years they do
these every four years I will I will
read a short paragraph from the uh 157
of the
recommendations is Adopt a time sharing
adjustment the high guidelines deviation
rate and the recommendations from survey
respondents speak to the overwhelming
need for New Hampshire to adopt a
statutory formula New Hampshire is
currently one of the nine states that
does not provide a formula in their
guidelines
many of these states are also in the
process of adopting or considering
adopting a time sharing formula when
adopting a time sharing adjustment the
guidelines deviation criteria should
also be
revamped
uh many of the deviation criteria relate
to time sharing so this report like all
the others as I pointed out
$116,000 and this is a state report it's
not a by
some organization or anything it's it's
done for the state and and is contracted
every four years and so uh the state the
the child support
um time sharing is what you have before
you is a parenting time
adjustment and
uh it will U satisfy all those demands
um
what else I can say um I do have a pro
and con if if you want or you yeah you
ahead um first the major recommendation
of the quadrennial review which is this
was to implement a formulaic parenting
time adjustment 1564 proposes a
presumptive zero order in the very
narrow circumstance when both incomes
and parenting time are equal or
approximately equal if and only if both
parties first agree to evenly split
add-on costs in contrast
1595 provides a broad formulaic
adjustment for any mix of incomes
parenting times and add-on costs using a
parenting time formula adopted by many
of the other states and supported by
judges attorneys and parents in the
survey conducted as part of the qural
review the need for a broad rather than
a narrow formula is reflected by data
that shows parenting time situations are
approximately evenly split between lower
and higher parenting time situations
additionally HB 1564 proposes a complex
deviation mechanism for the majority of
situations occurring outside the zero
order which would increase rather than
decrease the already high deviation rate
of
48% in New Hampshire um in contrast to
Broad formulaic approach of 1595 May
decrease the deviation rate by as much
as 1 half Based on data in the report so
that's what we're trying to achieve
second 1564 proposes to increase
self-support Reserve EX uh 130% of
federal poverty line in line with the
recommendations of the quadral review
1595 was unable to include the
recommendation due to legislative
drafting rules uh but would welcome this
amendment however 1595 does stand alone
without that you know both bills can be
passed and we'll get both things
achieved uh third 1595 incorporates the
quadrennial Reg
recommendation to shift child care
expenses and medical costs from income
deductions to add-on cost to be
consistent with the income shares
methodology adopted by New Hampshire
hb564 has not included the
recommendation uh so we've got that
added in here too 1595 amends the
ability to pay calculation to include
direct child costs by the obligor in
order to prevent the the obligor being
inadvertently forced below poverty level
this is consistent with the federal
2016 fifth in order to support proper
calculation of proposed changes HB
1595 corrects the pration of child costs
Beyond base child cost to also include
add-on costs to allow a fully functional
income shares
methodology as originally envisioned the
correction was identified in the 2004
310 uh commission report and affirmed in
2019 by the Supreme Court Anderson so
we're we're taking care the Anderson
Supreme Court decision that says the
legislature needs to fix this
formula um and that what it does to
ensure the that both the custodial and
non-custodial parents share and the
support responsib ability for their
children according to the relative uh
percentage of each parent income in
contrast 64 1564 leaves the current
pration mechanism
unchanged in summary HP 1595 provides a
more comprehensive solution for the same
cost while decreasing rather than
increasing
deviations which is the direction we
need to
go um in child support guidelines
additionally it also resolves a known
longstanding flaw in New Hampshire
income shares model which should further
decrease deviations by promoting
Equitable calculations in short while HB
1564 has Merit 1595 provid substantially
better bang for the buck in other words
you get a very comprehensive bill here
to do a lot for the same cost as
Finance
any questions any questions for
bill I seeing nonone representative
katab on
1564 thank you so this bill seeks to
well let me take a step back so in the
in the special uh Family Court committee
we heard much testimony on the need
to untie the judge's hands so to speak
because right now deviations aren't
allowed in the cases of shared parenting
time and so when particularly when the
kids are
5050 parenting time with either parent
and one parent uh we had a mom come in
that basically said that she was paying
so much to the other parent that you
know he was getting to take the kids on
vacation and out to dinner and she could
barely afford to pay her bills let alone
take the kids on vacation or out to
dinner um and so with that in mind I
think it's it's important that we kind
of untie the hands but that we do keep
the best interest of the children in
mind and so these are rebuttable
presumptions uh rep ball and I had had
worked together on the summer with with
getting together with some of the
stakeholders we've seen that over the
past decade with this much needed change
you know um thing after thing has been
ited so we did get together with several
family law attorneys from um nhj we got
together with nhla we got together with
some mediators and we tried to
see what would work that also wouldn't
ruin things for the families that are
agreeing because we've got 80% of
families that are agreeing and then the
20% who aren't so we want to make sure
that whatever we do is is going to work
and so that's we were able to come
together and and reach an agreement on
this bill I think it does many great
things it further it increases the
self-support reserve up from 115 to 130
which has long been recommended to do in
the quadrennial report so
I think that this bill addresses many of
the issues that we heard about in the
the special Family Court committee and I
do think that it will help many families
in New Hampshire without lowering the
child support so much that we have
unintended consequences that we don't
want to have so thank you any questions
katab we have two different bills before
us looking at the same
thing we can vote itl on both of them we
can vote one up the other down or we can
send them both to the Senate and let
proceed you mostly so I I'm just
confused because we have two bills out I
mean personally I would like to see
representative kab's pass and not uh
representative bigford so I don't know
how we go about
that well we have motions on both of the
bills so why don't we take one uh the
first one was 1564 there was a motion by
representative Deon of ought to pass
we'll take a mo we'll take a vote on
that and then we'll take a vote on 1595
which representative Bickford did you
make the motion to pass uh he did I
thought okay so I was just going to say
bought an amendment for that
1595 which was a uh domestic violence
thing that represent cab has her a bill
and some people said well maybe I'll
I'll throw it in that bill too so when
the time come when the time comes we'll
okay yes so I mean pass it around if we
move them out the pass then you may want
to look for a if if they're both out the
pass you may want to look for an
amendment don't we need to do the
amendment
yeah I mean you may be getting the
amendment for nothing I don't know but
yeah you don't know how we're going to
vote so you may not me need an amendment
I I don't
know you can do a floor Amendment after
we've passed things or what not if it's
that
simple okay so we were going to take a
OTP on
1564 take a vote and then take a vot on
it okay I just got asked to sub as a
chair in another committee are you
kidding
me
Finance
don't sure so the
motion recite what we're doing represent
uh I'm sorry uh so the motion is on
ought to pass on House Bill
1564 by representative D and if the
Clark would okay we will do 1564 first
representative D Simon seconded by
representative long this is
representative k pabs Bill the motion is
OTP on
1564 would the clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson yes representative
long yes representative desimon yes
representative
bfid representative katab yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative grman yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Greg
yes representative Raymond yes did I
call everyone 130 13 that be
everyone um okay and would uh
representative deimon uh hand me within
the next two seconds
you I I have
those emailed oh yeah and this ends the
um no exact session thank you I do that
all the time on 1564 and now we open it
on uh I open it on 1595 thank you which
Bickford's okay and wow you got a lot
gone and this is already out to pass
representative Bickford seconded by
representative panck this is on House
Bill 15
95 and here we go
cheer clerk please call the
RO chairman Pearson yes representative
long no representative
disimon representative
Bickford representative
katab
yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative Sidell yes
Representative grman
no representative Patrina will vote no
representative Greg no representative
Raymond
no we have
seven three four five
six 7even to six it passes OD a pass Six
it passes 7 to6 and representative
bigford if we could have a report on
that from you thank you Mr chairman can
I ask a procedural question you may
thank you sir what happens when we pass
two bills that are slightly in conflict
with each other but do the same thing
they go to
finance then they go to the Senate by
way of the house
floor
fascinating and people can uh craft
floor amendments to either one of these
along the way and that ends the uh exec
session on
1595 uh open the hearing uh no I don't I
open the I got to print this out the
exec session on House Bill 1511
representative Deb
Hobson's uh Little Bill it is a
um kind of a housekeeping item what it
does is ensures that New Hampshire
supports the best interest in
educational rights of the students and
so on by making sure that the Department
of Health and Human Services Bureau for
children's Behavioral Health notifies
the Department of Education on the Daye
a Cod order res signed I mean it's that
sexy right it's just that things uh we
the desire of the sponsor the desire of
others and the desire of you may
remember Isidor Rodriguez LeAndre from
the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities was that uh
reporting wasn't always done and this
will ensure it so therefore the chair
calls upon himself for a motion that
he's already spoken to and moves 1511
pass
me and I need a second who's who is i r
yeah I know that
oh okay so that's the reason I mean it
is like the ultimate of housekeeping it
just makes sure there's an agency
specifically tasked with
communication and you will see that in
the boldface lines 10 and 11 in the bill
that's all it does we had one written
piece of testimony by the the head of
disabilities
any
questions
comments all right seeing none I will
call the question the bill is 1511 the
motion is ought to pass move by The
Chair seconded by representative Gman
would the clerk please call the role
chairman Pearson yes representative long
yes representative disimon yes
representative bfid representative katab
yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panck yes representative sidel yes
representative Gman yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Greg yes representative Raymond yes 13
to
zero yeah consent any objections consent
uh you give me a blank sheet I'll take
it all right this closes the um SE
session on
15 whatever it is
1511 and give us a minute here to catch
up there is it okay I didn't yes to
consent okay thank
you uh we're getting in the the home
stretch
here
uh open the executive session now in
1282 representative Ball's Bill Alters
the time at which a child support
obligation ends uh there is an amendment
by Representatives D Simon and ball
Amendment
0453 this is House Bill
1282 and the chair will entertain a
amendment Mr chairman yes I would like
to make a motion that we adopt the
amendment
40453 yes 0453 and a
second second by representative thank
you and uh representative uh ball would
you please speak to the amendment to
your
bell yes if everyone recalls this is the
same bill that went we unanimously um
approved last year we did make um a
minor change it came back to us because
we I mistakenly use the term benefits
instead of child support but in
testimony it was brought to our
attention that we should clarify the um
charter schools and home education
programs um
so we did include that in here to make
sure that where there's nothing um left
loopholes if you recall um chairman this
was closing the loophole of when a child
uh turns 18 while they're still in
school but then they choose to drop out
of school and the original Bill said it
was whichever was later so they could
still be getting child support past the
of 18 and in the amendment this is
something that I deal with in my work
with the developmentally delayed and
other groups line 16 in your Amendment
uh it it no longer just says until the
child reaches 21 it adds or no longer
qualifies as a child with a disability
which stretches it a bit which it should
yes that was at a recommendation in the
um special committee on child care where
we're trying to get away from um putting
age 21 now so that we could link it to
another bill in case that um age should
uniform any questions for representative
ball on the
amendment the motion before us is
amendment 0453 on House Bill 1282 moved
by representative ball and seconded by
representative Bickford with the clerk
please call the role chairman Pearson
yes representative long yes
representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
katab yes representative McMan yes
representative ball yes representative
panck yes representative sidel yes
representative grman yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Greg yes representative Raymond yes 13
to Zer 13 to zero chair will entertain a
motion on
otpa representative ball
chairman thank you chairman parison I'd
like to move
OTP um
otpa please on House Bill 582 do we have
a second I'm sorry 1282 do we have a
second who seconds this representative
Greg any further
discussion the motion before us is ought
to pass as amended House Bill 1282
amended by
0453 moved by representative Paul
seconded by representative Greg the
clerk may call the
role chairman Pearson yes representative
long yes representative disimon
representative bfid representative
katab yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic representative Sidell yes
representative grman yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Greg yes representative Raymond yes 13
to zero and representative ball would
you get a uh a blurb on that uh please
within the next um one
seconds this really works well
1282 now I open an exact session on
1590 representative Longs bill training
regarding child abuse and neglect for
doctors and nurse practitioners and
Physicians assistants and so on and is
there an amendment coming uh actually if
I may uh yes you may I I'll move uh at
1590 inum study
and it's a legitimate
move somebody want to second that it
yeah I'll second that um forever
grateful and if I may uh uh training for
medical professionals is an important
requirement ensure an early detection of
abuse and neglect in children uh it's
also important to identify the best
training available which the
professionals weren't able to come up
with yet uh and also the process with
which we could log in log in those that
are taking it to assure that we're it's
it's meeting it its goal and also with
uh training that's updated often who's
going to be responsible for updating the
training um so therefore uh that that
group agreed to work with me or whomever
gets appointed to there and I'm more
than happy to get on that study
committee sure um uh so I'll move uh
that's why I'll move interim
study the motion before us is 1590
interim study moved by the Vice chair
and seconded by the chair any further
discussion would the clerk please call
the role chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
disimon representative bfid yes
representative katab yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative grman yes
representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes motion passes 130 13 to Z
the blurb by
representative
long oh here you go yeah it just came
certainly representative your committee
at oh we chugging here okay that ends
the executive session on 1590 can you
believe we are down to one I think and
that would be uh House Bill
1341 liability of grandparents to
provide assistance Chief sponsor
representative bigford um chair will
entertain a motion on the bill I take it
there's no
amendments representative make a motion
I'll make a motion of ought to pass
ought to pass bigford and who else
second a second representative
panic
okay
1341 and would you please speak to your
motion well this this again was a
recommendation of the quadrennial uh
review and I'll read that to you it's
very rather short says either repeal the
law providing for grandparent liability
to support the children of their unwed
minor children or add more specification
to it there are numerous justifications
to eliminate it it is not a a common
issue child support from the parent if
able should be prioritized and
establishing policies for consistent
treatment would require a lot of time
and resources for few cases more
specification would entail whether to
limit liability only to public
assistance cases
applications uh to both the
maternal and parental uh
paternal paternal and paternal
grandparents identification of income to
be used and several other specifications
which I believe is what I reported to
hearing
so anyway I'm trying to clean up these
review any questions for representative
Bickford the point of the bill is to say
grandparents are are not liable now
for uh supporting their
grandchildren anybody have a comment on
this one way or the
other representative Raymond oh um I
don't have a comment I just think it's
important and I appreciate uh
representative Bick Bird's work uh
getting these things cleaned up for us
so thank you thank you oh thank you good
work I took that as a
comment anyone else like it not like
it would you like to be recognized
represent you wouldn't okay I still
recognize you okay I see you right over
there
else the motion before us House Bill
1341 liability of grandparents to
provide assistance chief Chief sponsor
representative Bickford moved it OTP
Panic uh seconded uh clerk please call
the rooll chairman Pearson yep
representative long yes representative
disimon representative Bickford yes
representative katab yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative grman yes
representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes 13 to
zero any objection to consent
calendar seeing none on to consent
representative you get us a a committee
grandchildren call be you're on your own
good yes you're on your
own all right 1341 exec session is
it I don't have a printer I won't be by
a printer for two days if you could go
to the fourth floor and ask him to print
it out for you so I can give it to the
clerk
please could you put in another sentence
in effect saying we looked at it but
decided there was more we needed to
learn you know next to the last sentence
otherwise it just sort of gets to a
conclusion
abruptly okay oh which is true but why
should we enter and study it um I would
suggest a sentence in there something
like well saying like
uh while we learned much through the
hearings we realize there's more to this
when we you know blah blah
blah and if you owe a
please